[Music]
so I'm going to launch right into it I
like this story as well this is the
story of Noah and the flood and then the
Tower of Babel which I think are
juxtaposed very interestingly the Tower
of Babel is one of those stories like
Cain and Abel that's only a few lines
long it's like a fragment in some sense
although the story of Noah is quite a
well-developed narrative but like the
other stories that we've covered it is
relevant at multiple levels of analysis
simultaneously and so what I'm going to
do to begin with is to start with some
background information so some
psychological background information so
that the story makes sense and the first
thing that I'd like to I'd like to make
a case for is that the you're bringing
to bear on the world an a priori
perceptual structure and that's really
an embodied structure and it's a
consequence of the three and a half
billion years that you've spent putting
your body together which is a tremendous
amount of time not only your body but
your mind of course because your mind is
part of your body and very much embedded
within it you know you tend to think
that you have your brain in your head
and it's sort of splitting separate from
the rest of your body but it's not
really true your tremendous massive
system of neurons running through your
entire body
autonomic small neurons in the autonomic
nervous system then are on the central
nervous system so that's a lot of
neurons and then your central nervous
system of course enables you to exercise
voluntary control over your musculature
and also to receive information from it
your brain is really distributed through
your body one of the things you may not
know is that people who are paraplegic
can walk if you if you suspend them
above a treadmill their legs will walk
by themselves with no voluntary control
so your spine is capable of quite
complex
tivity in fact when you walk mostly it's
a controlled fall and mostly your spine
is doing it and so so anyways the point
of all that is that you don't have a
blank slate consciousness that's
interpreting a world that manifests
itself as sacred gated objects in some
straightforward sense you have a built
in interpretive system that's
extraordinarily deeply embedded and
invisible because you might think about
it as the implicit structure of your
unconscious it's it what it's what gives
rise to your conscious experience and
and it presents you with the world that
that's one way of thinking about it and
it's a good way of thinking about it the
psychoanalytic way of thinking about it
as well as the neuroscientific way of
thinking about it because one of the
things that's pretty interesting about
modern neuroscientists especially the
top-rate ones and those are usually the
ones that are working on emotions as far
as I've been able to tell are are often
quite enamored of the psychoanalyst
Jacques panksepp was a good example of
that because they came to understand
that the psychoanalyst insistence on
underlying unconscious personified
motivations was actually an accurate
reflection of how the brain worked so to
think of yourself as a loose collection
of autonomous spirits it's governed by
some overarching identity is a
reasonable way of thinking about it the
question is or a question arises from
that is what is the nature of this a
priori structure that you use to
interpret the world and I think the
clearest answer to that is that it's a
story and you live inside the story and
that's very very interesting to me
because I believe I have a couple of
videos that lay this out I believe that
Darwinian presuppositions are at least
as fundamental as Newtonian
presuppositions I actually think they're
more fundamental and that the fact that
we've evolved story-like structures
through which to interpret the world
indicates to me that there's something
deeply true about story like structure
they're true at least insofar as the
fact that we've developed them means
that here we are living and that it's
taken three and a half billion years to
develop them there they're highly
functional and so we don't have much
better definition of truth than highly
functional you know that that's about as
good as it gets
partly because we're limited creatures
and we don't have on the siient
knowledge and so the best we can do with
our knowledge generally speaking is to
know its functionality and improve it
when it fails to work properly I think
the scientific method actually does that
and so the fact that we've evolved a
story like structure through which to
interpret the world
that's pretty damn interesting it says
something fundamental about stories and
it's it's strange in the same way that
the fact that we have hemispheric
specialization for the known and the
unknown
or for chaos and order order and chaos
Ori respectively also says something
fundamental about the nature of the
world if you assume that you know we've
evolved to reflect the structure of the
world broadly speaking that's obviously
not just the physical structure the
atoms and the molecules but all of the
patterned manifestations of the physical
molecules as they build structures of
increasing complexity across time that
would include human interactions and all
of and political interactions and
economic act interactions Familia
interactions all of those things that
are a very important part of our reality
but perhaps in some sense not as
fundamental as the physical attributes
that the physicists concentrate on so we
live in stories and also I want to talk
to you a little bit about stories and
about their structure because when you
understand a little bit about the
structure of stories then a whole array
of things about mythology all of a
sudden make overwhelming Sampson so
useful because what you see is that many
of the things that are standard
occurrences in your life everyone's like
them are portrayed universally in
mythology and it's very helpful because
first of all it D it D isolates you one
of the things you learn as a clinical
psychologist
contre the anti psychiatrists let's say
is that diagnosis is often a relief to
people you know there's a problem with
being diagnosed because then you might
be labeled and then the label can follow
you for the rest of your life and once
you're labeled as something then strange
things happen around you that so often
reinforce that label maybe you start
acting it out more or you dot it as an
identity but there's a flip side of that
which is that the last thing that you
ever want to hear when you go see a
physician or psychologist is you know
I've never seen a case like yours before
right that is not a relief man because
if the message is I've never heard
anything like what you're telling me the
outcome is either going to be not so
good for you or you're not going to get
listened to it all right because you're
such an anomaly that you're you're
actually your existence is annoying to
the integrated knowledge structure of
the medical professional that you're
attempting to receive advice from well
it's definitely the case because they
you know if you can be put in a box then
the Box tells the doctor what to do with
you and that's actually a relief to the
doctor but also a relief to you right
because you want to know so you come and
you say look I can't go out of my house
much anymore
I'm afraid on elevators I have heart
palpitations as I sometimes they end up
in the emergency room increasingly my
interactions in the world are restricted
I find myself staying at home afraid I'm
going to died of a heart attack and the
psychologist says well you have a
agoraphobia it's like lots of people
have that and here is usually how it
develops and here's the treatment course
and you know we can probably do
something about that and it's like well
you're not going to die of a heart
attack now probably that's a real relief
you're not crazy in a completely unique
way and you're crazy in a way that might
be treatable you know and it's such a
relief
because people come in there with a pile
of snakes of indeterminate magnitude and
they walk out with one manageable snake
and it's still a snake but you know one
manageable snake beats a Hydra right so
all right so so back back to stories so
the stories that that we tell and that
we live in are fundamentally ways that
we deal with the complexity of the world
and the fundamental problem with the
world as far as I can tell is that not
only is it complex beyond your
comprehension but the complexity shifts
in unpredictable ways so that's the
Darwinian conundrum actually that's why
Darwinism seems to be a practical
necessity with regards to the
continuation of life because because the
complexity changes unpredictably you
can't necessarily tell what's going to
work in the future and so the Darwinian
process solves that by generating quasi
random variations and letting whichever
one by happenstance happens to work in
that environment survive now it's not
random precisely because the underlying
structure is conserved it's very rare
that a child would be born with an extra
arm or something like that and like the
skeletal structure that you inhabit is
shared by animals going way way back in
evolutionary history there's a lot of
conservation and in the evolutionary
process but so there's variation within
conservation like music it's a good it's
a good way of thinking about it so the
the story that we tell have exactly the
same structure they have this is core
element with variations and so alright
I'll turn to the stories and so the
first problem as I mentioned is come a
complexity problem things are just too
complicated to get a handle on and that
actually has serious consequences
because what happens to everyone
eventually is that their lives become so
complicated that they die so and that
and many terrible things can happen you
on the way to dying as well that are
complex complexity related right you can
develop a serious illness that you can't
get a handle on you can hit a what would
you call an impasse in your relationship
that you cannot get past and see no way
out of
that happens to people quite frequently
people who are suicidal for example they
often feel like they've been backed into
a corner that know that they have no
options they have no good options no
matter which way they turn there's
something terrible to face and they
can't see any way out of it and
sometimes that's more true than you'd
like to think because we also tend to
like to think that people's problems are
primarily psychological but they're not
now that's one thing you learn quite
rapidly as a clinician is that most of
the time people don't come to you
because they have mental illness they
come to you because they have a
complexity management problem their
lives have got out of hand on them and
they don't know how to get them back
under control and so all sorts of things
can do that and then of course that can
make you anxious or depressed it can
trigger all sorts of illnesses but the
fundamental problem is still that things
have got beyond you and that actually
has a psychophysiological cost that
isn't merely psychological you have a
limited amount of capacity from from
from a resource perspective to deal with
emergent complexity it just is just not
enough of you you just you'll exhaust
your psychophysiological resources if
you get into a situation that's too
complex well that's what that's what the
idea of chaos represents it represents
that underlying complexity that can
manifest itself at any time and it can
manifest itself for example if you're if
you wake up in the morning and you know
you feel an ache of some sort and
perhaps it's nothing and you ignore it
but it gets worse and you end up going
to a hospital and you find out perhaps
for example that you have pancreatic
cancer and you're going to live for six
months and that's the end of that and so
it's it's it's it's at that moment that
you break through the thin ice that
everyone walks on and you see what's
underneath and what's underneath is the
in eradicable complexity of life and
that's chaos and that's now it's taken
people a long long time to get a grip on
this conceptual what would you call
conceptual schema and and human beings
have done it mostly with image and story
before they've been able to do it in any
particulate matter and so there are a
set of images that represent this
underlying chaos and one of them is the
dragon of chaos that that precisely that
and that's the dragon that the hero goes
out to confront that's the symbol of the
unknown it's the thing that lurks
underneath it's the thing that also
guards treasure because I'm me unknown
there's possibility also the water that
that was there we talked about in the
Mesopotamian creation myth the water
that's there at the beginning both the
salt and the fresh water is often a
symbol of pre cosmogonic chaos often
people have dreams for example some of
you had this dream I suspect you'll
dream that you're in a house that you
know well and all of a sudden you
discover a new room or a set of new
rooms or maybe a set of rooms in the
basement and often the rooms are not
well organized and they're full of water
those are very common things and what
that means is that you've broken through
the constraints of your conscious self
understanding to a new domain of
possibility but a new domain that needs
a tremendous amount of work it says well
here the new part of you but it's not
well developed there's it's flooded it's
flooded with chaos essentially and it's
water I think partly because chaos is
not only what you fall into when you're
not expecting it but it's also the
unknown that you confront forthrightly
and generate new things out of and water
is a symbol of life especially in the
desert and of course water life is
dependent on water and so water is a
natural symbol to utilize when you're
talking about something that's
life-giving but also potentially deadly
because a little bit of water well
that's a drink but a lot of water that's
a shipwreck right and so and those are
the those are the extremes now there are
accounts that are sort of sub texts in
Genesis and they all swear in the Old
Testament of God conquering a great
monster Leviathan or or Bama that has
these sort of serpent Isle elements and
making the world at the consequence of
that conflict so there's this idea that
the world creating force which we've
talked about as the logos is the thing
that continually confronts chaos and
that one way of thinking about chaos is
as a predatory reptilian monster and
often one that lives in the depths are
perhaps underwater and part of that I
think is because we actually use our
predator detection circuit to do this
sort of pre cognitive process and so
that the notion fundamentally is
anything that threatens you
instantaneously is something that your
predator detection circuit should be
working with it's fast its its spout
it's low resolution it doesn't have a
lot of ideas but it's really really fast
and that also accounts for capability
and tendency to very rapidly treat
people who upset our conceptual
structures as enemies of the predatory
variety we can fall into that in no time
flat because it's it's the archetype if
something comes along to knock you for a
loop
it's a shark it's something that lurks
under the water it's something that will
pull you down it's an enemy and and you
should get prepared and that's a
reasonable defensive strategy even
though it also has its dangers and can
sometimes be wrong so the landscape
within which we have to erect our
stories it's fundamentally one of an
overarching chaos a chaos that exceeds
our capacity to comprehend in any sense
individually familial socially
economically we're always threatened by
the collapse of the structures that we
inhabit constantly we have to work well
it's like you own a house you know how
much times has been maintaining a house
well a lot and why is that is because
the house falls apart because you're
stupid and the house falls apart well
because you do repairs wrong or you
ignore things right and I'm saying this
actually for technical reasons the house
falls apart because you're incompetent
but even if you're confident the house
falls apart right it's just entropy and
so things have a proclivity to fall
apart on their own so you just have to
run like mad just to keep them doing
what they're supposed to be doing and
then of course that is conflict
by your own willful blindness and
inadequacy as a repair person refusal to
attend and all those other things so so
that's a very classic idea which will
return to one of the ideas that Mircea
Eliade a--
a famous history of religions extracted
from a very large corpus of flood myths
was the idea that the earth is
periodically flooded for two reasons one
is things fall apart just entropy the
straight entropy it's I don't remember
which law of thermodynamics that is but
it's one of the big laws of
thermodynamics it's one of the top three
man things fall apart of their own
accord and that's one of the things that
we have to contend with and then the
rate at which things fall apart is sped
by the sins of men that's the other idea
and you know that everyone knows that
because you know you know your car
breaks down in the highway you thank god
that's so inconvenient and then you you
know you shake your fist at the sky and
then there's part of you in the back
your mind that goes God you know I knew
that rattle that I wasn't paying
attention to actually signified
something you know and I knew I should
have paid attention to it and I didn't
and now I'm in the situation that I'm in
now and you know I know I bet you this
happens to people two or three times a
week is they do something stupid that
they know they shouldn't have done that
they told themselves not to do mere
seconds before and they know the boy
says don't do that yeah yeah you do it
you can get nailed for it exactly the
way that you knew you would get nailed
for it and then you're hurt doubly
because not only did it fall apart but
you're the idiot that made it fall apart
knowing full well that was going to fall
apart and ignoring it and so that's the
idea behind the notion that there are
two reasons that things fall apart
thermodynamic entropy and the proclivity
of people not to attend to things they
know they should attend to and partly we
do that because if a problem emerges it
always announces itself unless it's a
really really tiny problem and you're
approaching it voluntary voluntarily it
always announces itself with negative
emotion and that's part of the predator
detection circuit it announces itself in
frustration
or disappointment or emotional pain or
grief or the paramount one anxiety and
and no wonder because it's a problem
right and the logical one the logical
response is it's just sort of freeze in
the face of the problem but of course if
it's a problem that has to be addressed
and solved freezing it and turning away
from it is not a good solution because
since things tend to fall apart on their
own accord if you just leave the thing
alone that's problematic it's just going
to get worse not better which is one of
the things that's very annoying about
life so for example you know if you get
a warning message from the tax
department the probability that ignoring
that will make it go away is zero right
what will happen instead is that the
more you ignore it the larger it will
grow and if you ignore it long enough
then it will turn into something large
enough to eat you and that will be the
end of you I read in Harper's Magazine
at one point that people would rather be
mugged than audited and so I believe
that because the mugging man that's over
it's like a couple of minutes a sheer
terror lost your wallet the way you walk
the audit that's like that's like a semi
fatal disease so so that's chaos now
it's the idea here to is that that's the
chaos that's the psychological idea is
that that's also the chaos that whatever
is being represented in genesis as the
Spirit of God extracts order out of at
the beginning of time and it's also that
which we're constantly contending with
as we struggle in the same manner to
construct and maintain habitable worlds
so it's brilliant it's brilliant you
know when I first put together the
relationship between what Iliad II
called the pre cosmogonic chaos and the
predator predatory landscape that
surrounded our ancestors and the manner
in which were structured neurologically
to respond to all of that I thought it
was it was like an amazing epiphany
because it's self-evidently the case
that the world is too complicated for us
to deal with and that's one of the
problems that we face on an ongoing
basis and then the question is well what
do you do about that and if you ignore
it it gets worse so
Laurene it doesn't work and so we know
what doesn't work and so if ignoring it
doesn't work then attending to it might
work and then I found out with the
Egyptians for example that Horus was the
god of the tension and the same thing
happened among the Mesopotamians with
far duck and his ring of eyes it's like
what's the way to forestall the
catastrophe of things falling apart and
the answer to that is by attending to
them voluntarily attending to them and
that slots very nicely into the hero
mythology that promotes the idea that if
there's a dragon in the whereabouts in
in the near in the neighborhood let's
say that hiding in the basement just
makes it grow larger it's time to go out
and confront the damn thing and the
general stories are as well you might
get killed because it's a dragon but
it's only might as opposed to definitely
will get killed if it happens to attack
you at 3 in the morning at home when
you're hungover and it's been a bad day
and you don't have your you know art
your sword and your shield at the ready
which is generally what happens to
people who avoid things so it's not
something that should be recommended
you're screwed both ways that's one of
the things that's so nice about being
deeply pessimistic it's so freeing
because one of the things well it's very
frequent it's such a relief and it's
really a useful habit to develop is
sometimes no matter what you do you're
in trouble and that's a relief because
then you can stop scrabbling around for
the way out there's no way out man it's
like you can pick murder
you know wretched death a or slightly
less wretched death be something like
that and and I know that's a terrible
way of looking at things but it is
extraordinarily useful to understand
that many times you get your choice
boils down to picking the least bad
option and if that's all you can do if
that's what how life is revealing itself
to you it's like well more power to you
the least bad option that's the best you
can do and and and it's good enough
especially compared to the alternative
which is the most bad option so
all right now so the fundamental reality
of things is complexity beyond
comprehension and then the question is
well how is it that you manage that and
partly you manage that and this is where
the image of the patriarchal order comes
in in the positive manner I might point
out because in the absence of
patriarchal structure for lack of a
better lexicon
there's nothing but chaos and I wouldn't
recommend chaos because it's it there's
a lot of it and there isn't that much of
you and if you think you can handle it
without an a priori structure and
without a sociological structure
surrounding you then you don't know
anything at all about human beings
because one of the things I've noticed
for example is that it's it's
unbelievable the degree to which our
sanity depends on a functioning
sociological structure and here's why
well first of all you kind of need to
know what to do every day you have to
have a routine because you're an animal
you know on you know if you have a dog
or a cat dogs are really good example
this dogs like routine they like to be
walked the number of times a day that
they're supposed to be walked and they
get quite sick very rapidly if you don't
if you don't routinize they're they're
days children are exactly the same way
now you can overdo it right but still
you know you need to know approximately
when you should get up should be
approximately the same every day you
need to know approximately you're going
when you're going to eat you need to
know what you're going to eat you need
to know who you're going to eat with you
need to know where to buy your food it's
like 80% of your life 70% of your life
something like that consists of those
things that you do every single day that
you repeat and those are often the
things that people think about as the
trivial elements of their life but one
of the things I would like to point out
to you if you do the mathematics I did
this with a client of mine who was
having hard time putting his child to
bed they were having a fight every night
and I knew by that time the studies
indicate that most parents only spend 20
minutes per day of one-on-one time with
their child now the reason for that is
that people are busy and it's actually
not that easy to parse out 20 minutes of
one-on-one time it's a lot bloody
more time than you think but that's all
there is 20 minutes he is spending like
40 minutes a day fighting with this kid
trying to get the kid to go to bed and
that's not very entertaining you know
you think was just having a scrap with
the Keita both going to bed but it's no
no no no if it happens every day
it's a catastrophe so you do the math so
we'll say five hours a week for the sake
of argument just to keep it simple it's
20 hours a month it's 240 hours a year
that's six 40-hour work weeks that guy
was basically spending a month and a
half of work weeks doing absolutely
nothing but having a wretched time
fighting with his son trying to get him
to go to bed horrible
right that's just way too much time to
spend doing something like that if you
want to actually have a positive
relationship with someone because it's
just too it's just too punishing and so
well so you need structure you need
predictability and you need more of it
than you think
just to keep you saying now if you're
lucky and and maybe a bit odd you can
deviate 5% from the norm or 10% from the
norm or something like that carefully
and cautiously as long as the rest of
you is all well ordered in a normative
manner you might be able to get away
with that and you might be able to
sustain it across time and people might
be able to tolerate you if you do it or
maybe you'll get really lucky and you
happen to be creative but reasonably
well put together and people will
actually be happy that there's something
idiosyncratic and unique about you but
even under those circumstances mostly
what you want is to have a routine it's
discipline its predictable and bloody
well stick to it you're going to be way
healthier and happier and saner if you
do that and then the other thing that
you need because this is one of the
things the psychoanalyst thought wrong I
think is that they overestimated the
degree to which sanity was a consequence
of internal being properly structured
internally you know because from the
psychoanalytic point of view you're sort
of an ego and that ego is inside you of
course it rests on an unconscious
structure but the purpose of
psychoanalysis is to sort out that
unconscious structure and the ego on top
of it and to make you a fully
an autonomous individual but there's a
problem with that because the reason
that you're saying as a fully functional
and on Thomas human being isn't because
you've organized your psyche even though
that's important the reason that you're
saying if you're a wit if you have a
well organized unconscious an ego is
because other people can tolerate having
you around for reasonably extensive
periods of time and will cuff you across
the back of the head every time you do
something so stupid that people will
dislike you permanently if you continue
and so what people are doing to each
other all the time just non-stop is
broadcasting sanity signals back and
forth right it's like you smile at
people if they're well if they're not
not only behaving properly but behaving
in a way that you would like to see them
continue to behave you frown at them if
they're not you ignore them if they're
not you shun them you you roll your eyes
at them you manifest a disgust face you
don't listen to them you interrupt them
you won't cooperate with them you won't
compete with them it's like you're
blasting signals at other people about
how to regulate their behavior so
frequently well it just makes up all of
your social interaction that's why we
face each other and we have emotional
displays on our face and we're looking
at each other's eyes and we know exactly
we know as much as we can about what's
going on with each other given that we
don't have immediate access to the
contents of their consciousness and so
partly what you're doing with your
routine is establishing yourself as a
credible reliable trustworthy
potentially interesting human being who
isn't going to do anything too erratic
at any moment and everyone else is
around there tapping you into shape
making sure that that's exactly what you
are and that's how you stay sane and so
what happens to people too if they don't
have a routine and they get isolated as
they start to drift and they drift badly
because the world is too complicated for
you to keep it organized all by yourself
you just cannot do it so a lot of our so
we outsource the problem of sanity and
it's very intelligent that we outsource
the problem of sanity because sanity is
an impossibly complex problem and so the
way that we manage the incredibly
complex
we have a very large number of brains
working simultaneously on the problem
all the time it's like a stock market
for sanity and it's partly I use that I
use that definition with purpose because
the stock market does the same kind of
impossible thing right because it tries
to price things which is impossible
there's how many things are there like a
billion how in the world do you decide
what the price is you can't decide what
the price is that's why you have a stock
market as well in the free market I mean
for for consumer goods is everyone's
voting on what the price of everything
is all the time that's the way we figure
it out because it's actually it's
technically impossible that's partly why
the stock market explodes now and then
and there's bubbles and all that sort of
thing but anyways the point is things
are chaotic in Ellis in Wonderland when
Ellis goes down the rabbit hole
that's the underworld right so now she's
gone into the sub structure of being and
she meets the Red Queen and the Red
Queen is mother nature and mother nature
is running around yelling off with her
heads off with their heads which is of
course what mother nature does and she
tailed Ellis in my kingdom you have to
run as fast as you can just to stay in
the same place and that's exactly right
and that's a description of in fact
evolutionary biologists I call just
picked up on that phrase they call it
the Red Queen problem and the Red Queen
problem is
everything's after you all the time and
you're not smart enough to do anything
about it
Ord enough about and so that's a
permanent existential problem so how do
you deal with that you've got a
biological structure so your embodiment
is part of the solution to the problem
and then your enculturated and because
you're enculturated you're taught a lot
of things that you need to know but
mostly what you're taught is how to
communicate with other people in an
acceptable manner and then once you can
communicate with people in an acceptable
manner then you can outsource your
problems constantly but you're doing
constantly and so we're in this
continual dynamic exchange of
problem-solving so if you're a
socialized person that's what you get
access to and that's something to know
if you're going to have kids and I
mentioned
I think in a previous lecture the PERT
the purpose of being a parent for very
young children is to make your children
exceptionally socially desirable by the
age of four because if you can do that
they're set because everyone wants them
around and as soon as everybody wants
them around they want to play with them
they want to cooperate when they want to
compete with them it's like the door is
open the door is open and they stay
saying because they've got all sorts of
people who actually like them that are
helping them out and so that's your goal
is to make them as socially acceptable
as you possibly can socially desirable
as you possibly can and that doesn't
mean you render them obedient without
spirit right that's that's a tyrants
motive of enforcing social acceptability
it's like never do anything wrong
well that's not any way to I mean that's
a good piece of advice you know like but
it's missing the other half which is do
a bunch of things that are right so that
so that people are thrilled to have you
around and to and encourage that that's
what you want to do as a parent as well
as inculcating the order and so you know
one in this little diagram I indicated
that there's God the Father with the Sun
behind him and he's ruling over this
walled city so he's like the Metis
spirit of the walled city it's very very
nice
very nice image brilliant image so it is
the collective spirit of the city that's
another way of thinking about it or the
collective spirit of the city across
time or the collective spirit of the
force that built and maintained the city
across time even better and that's
associated with the Sun because it's a
it's it's it's associated with
enlightenment and illumination and all
of those things that we associate with
higher consciousness and vision it's a
brilliant image and then I overlaid this
so now of course the patriarchal aspect
of existence can become tyrannical it
does that quite regularly it's one of
the existential dangers of human
civilizations that civilization is a
medication for chaos but it can spin out
of control in and of itself and become
its own sort of problem which is like a
hyper order problem
which then produces a chaos problem so
every solution carries within it certain
problems right because no solution is
perfect and so you have to keep things
in balance but it's one of the reasons
that I'm really let's call it irritated
about the postmodernists because they
keep yammering about the patriarchy and
it's very very annoying because because
it's self-evident that social structures
are tyrannical it's like that's not news
folks that's obvious but that's not all
they are and it's it's there it's the
reduction of the entire complex solution
let's say to a unit dimensional problem
it's just Thai tyranny it's like no
actually it's not just tyranny if you
spent six months somewhere that was just
tyranny you'd know the difference very
very rapidly and that doesn't mean that
everyone doesn't give up a pound or two
or ten or twenty a flesh to participate
even in the society that's as free as at
Western society is we all get crushed
and molded by the tyrannical force of
social convention but at least in
principle the benefit is worth the cost
and then it's also up to you to make
sure that you don't sacrifice more to
the group than you should and you can
start to tell if you're sacrificing more
to the group than you should because you
start to become resentful of other
people that's part of them that's part
of the psychological mechanism that's
informing you of that so it's up to you
to fight against you know the
overarching pressure for conformity to
retain your individual logos let's say
but that's sort of your problem it's
like the group wants you to behave now
if you could behave and be creatively
productive so much the better but that's
pretty damn rare so the group generally
tends to settle just for behave and
there's a tyrannical element of that but
what the hell is the alternative it's
you know our society is based on
consensus and the consensus is based on
the sacrifice of a certain sacrifice of
individuality
even though individuality is absolutely
necessary as a revitalizing force
the society it's a very tight touch
tough thing to manage properly so
anyways you have the your physiological
structure as your first line of ordering
in relationship to chaos because your
body presents you with the world in a
certain way and then the second line of
defense is something like the
sociological structure that you can have
it we could call those the competency
hierarchies or something like that and
thank God for them because you know
maybe you're going to be able to
specialize in one or two things in your
life or five things but there's 300
things you need to know and if it's just
you you know you'll be doing your genius
level mathematics while your bath tub is
leaking all over your all over your
bathroom floor and that's not so good so
you can call a plumber and hooray for
that so you know we tend to cooperate to
keep chaos under control and we tend to
cooperate to keep order under control
and that's the political dialogue right
you maintain the culture to keep chaos
under control and we balance the
cultural property to keep the culture
under control and that way we get to
live reasonably peacefully reasonably
productively for a reasonable amount of
time and that's the best that we can do
and we should have some gratitude when
that's working because the default
condition of things is that not only do
they not work very well they work worse
and worse over time all by themselves so
anytime anything is working you should
just be amazed by it all right so what
does the frame look like well I think it
looks something like this and this is as
far as I can tell this is the bare-bones
this is the bare bones of a variety of
things it's a bear bowling story it's a
bear bowling conceptual framework it's a
bear bowling design to speak in high
daguerreian terms it's like it's the
bare bones world that you live in you're
always in one of these worlds there's no
getting out of them you can move from
one to another but you're always in a
world like this and so this is the world
that you're in you're somewhere because
you have to be somewhere now you might
not know where that is
which means that somewhere that you are
is chaotic in which case you need to go
over your past in great detail and
figure out where you are so
you're lost right here you're lost and
the problem with being lost is when
you're lost you don't know where to go
and the problem with not knowing where
to go is there's a million places that
you could go and a million places is too
many places for you to go without dying
so being lost is not good so you need to
know where you are one of the things
that we built online my partners and I
have this program called past authoring
that helps people lay out the narrative
of their past to identify to break their
life down into six stages epochs we call
them and then to identify the
emotionally significant moments in each
epoch and to write them out what
happened negatively what happened
positively what the consequences were
what do you derive from it perhaps what
you could have done differently perhaps
what you learn from it all of that so
that you can narrow in zero in on
determining precisely where it is that
you are right now and people are often
loath to do that because they actually
don't want to know they'd rather be
spread out in a sort of half-blind
manner in the fog hoping that the place
that they're at is better than it really
is and deluding themselves by remaining
vague than to figure out I'm right here
right now with these specific problems
but it's actually better to do that
because if you have a set of specific
problems and you've really narrowed them
down and really specified them then you
could probably start fixing them and you
can start fixing them in Mike microwaves
bit by bit but there's no way you can do
that without knowing where you are it's
impossible and you can kind of tell if
you don't know where you are it's quite
straightforward if you are haunted by
reveries of the past for events that are
older than approximately eighteen months
if they continue to come up in your mind
over and over and your dreams over and
over
you haven't extracted the world out from
your past experiences the potential is
still trapped in the past and to
confront the potential means to confront
the dragon of the past and of course
that's terrifying
and it seems seriously be terrifying so
for example maybe your vague and
ill-formed and ill-defined because you
will be
used her dad when you were a child four
years old something like that and maybe
R abused by a family member because
that's generally who does the abusing
and so that just makes it works and then
what that means is that you've got a
implicit you had an implicit encounter
with malevolent evil that know you've
had a direct encounter with malevolent
evil but you have an implicit hypothesis
of malevolent evil that's plaguing you
it's still there it's trapped in the
memories right it's trapped in the
representational structure and as an
adult you're now faced with the
necessity of articulating that fully
before you have any chance whatsoever of
freeing yourself from it and so that's
no joke lots of times people have to go
into the past that's what this I grant
lists do and say and say look here is
something came along just bloody well
knocked me over and it isn't even that I
repressed it which which I think was we
will talk about Freud's errors because
Freud was a genius so we'll just leave
him alone but but sometimes it's not
repression it's just the terrible things
happen to people at such a young age
that there isn't a bloody chance in hell
that they can figure out why they happen
or what to do with them or what they
mean and then you can carry that with
you and you carry it with you it's like
here your your body encounters the world
in two stages and it happens very
rapidly well it can extend over years
but the initial stage has happened very
rapidly so for example if you're walking
down the road and you hear a large noise
be a loud noise behind you go like this
that's a predator defense response by
the way you crouch down and that's to
stop something from jumping on your back
and getting at your neck too easily
that's like a few million two hundred
milliseconds it's really fast or even
faster than that and it better be
because something like a snake like will
say it can nail you just right now so
you better be fast but it's low
resolution it's like danger snake
something like that or danger predatory
cap it's that fast and then you can
unravel that and categorize it but that
takes time you do that with emotion and
then you do it with cognition you can do
that with long term thinking you know
because maybe you've encountered someone
specifically malevolent and predatory at
work that happens to people a lot
as a as a destructive bully and who
seems to have no positive function
whatsoever and is only living that out
and then you you know you don't know
what to do about it so you're you're in
prey mode I don't mean this kind of mode
although that would help too but I mean
you're acting like a prey animal and
then you have this terribly complex
thing to decompose which is what the
hell's up with this person why are they
making my life miserable what is it
about me that allows them to make my
life miserable
that's a nasty little road to walk down
and you're stuck with having to you're
stuck with having to decompose it maybe
you can't maybe
formulating an explicit philosophy of
good and evil to deal with something
malevolent in your environment actually
just happens to be beyond you and that
could easily be it's certainly the case
for people who are young and it's the
case for plenty of adults as well it's
no simple thing to math to manage it's
something to that often soldiers who
have post-traumatic stress disorder have
to do because they've encountered
terrible things maybe they're Dunham or
ran into them they need to update their
moral model of the world or if they end
up in something close enough closely
approximating hell anyway so you need to
know where you are
that's this what is where are you so
you're navigating your navigator you're
a sailor on an ocean man that's what
that's what you are you're a mobile
creature you're going from point A to
point B all the time you know it's
sitting there glued to a rock like some
brainless you know sea creature there's
a funny little creature called a Hydra
very simple little creature in its
juvenile stage it has a brain because it
swims around but then when it turns into
an adult it latches itself to iraq and
promptly digests its brain because if
you're just sitting on a rock and you're
not moving you don't need a brain so but
that's not our issue right we're
resuming in the world and so we're
navigating agents so to navigate if
there's two things you need to know the
first is where the hell are you exactly
precisely right razorsharp
what's good about you and what's bad
about you by your own by your own
reckoning you don't have to you can ask
other people but this is a game you play
yourself it's like as far as I'm
concerned
I'm taking start what is it that's okay
about me and what needs some work and
you go to watch to not be too
self-critical when you're doing that too
because that can just be another kind of
flaw and then the next is okay well
where are you going what's your
destination well and that's what the
frame is now you know you could do that
in a very sophisticated way and you do
that by thinking consciously about who
it is that you are in an articulated
manner and where you want to go and why
and how you're going to get there and
people hardly ever do that that is
that's come as such an absolute shock to
me as an educator I just because one of
the other programs I use this in my
classes what are the other programs in
this suite of programs is called the
Future authoring program and I started
developing it my maps of meaning class
which is where some of this materials
from and I got students to write about
their past it's like okay we're talking
about stories so let's tell your story
who are you how do you get here what are
you now that usually helps people put
things to rest although it's quite
stressful well you're doing it stress
goes up when you're doing it and maybe
you feel miserable for a couple of weeks
and then stress goes down and it stays
down so that's and that's also why
people don't do it because who the hell
wants to have their stress go up but if
it's temporary it's a sacrifice so then
the next issue is well where are you
going and one of the things that and
this I just still I cannot understand is
students that have been in education
system for 15 years 14 years high end
students most of them not once in their
whole bloody life did anyone ever get
them to sit down for like a day and say
alright justify your existence it's like
well seriously it's like here you are in
university you're taking a bunch of
courses you've got some sort of vague
career plan it's like defend the damn
thing a bit since you're going to go
live it and everything you're staking
everything on it it's like what's your
damn plan and why are you so convinced
that it's not the plan of a babbling
fool because if you haven't thought
about it then it is and if you really
want to go out there and live that out
you know one of the things Carl Jung
said was that you you're in a story
whether you know it or not
and and then he made two nice comments
about that if it's someone else's story
you're probably going to get a bit part
and it might not be the one you want and
if it's a story that you don't know it
might be one with a really bad ending or
maybe it's just bad period with a worse
ending and if you don't know what the
story that you're living out is maybe
that's the one you know maybe you got
that from your mother you got it from
your grandmother you got it from your
aunt or god only knows where you picked
it up because you pick up things like
mad because that's what human beings are
like so maybe you're living a malevolent
tragedy unconsciously and then one thing
you might ask yourself is well how
wretched and miserable is your life
let's had futile to that how wretched
miserable and futile is your life and
you might say well yeah seventy percent
on each count it's like then you're
probably unconsciously living out a
malevolent tragedy and maybe that's not
for the best it's either that or the
whole universe hates you right or 70
percent hates you you know so so anyways
you know we got students to start
writing in detail about not what they
wanted it's not a career thing because
that's the closest people usually get is
they have a career plan it's like no no
it's not a career plan that's that's
peripheral important but peripheral it's
like all right you got three years man
you're going to live them anyways devote
those three years to setting the world
up around you so that it's the best it
could possibly be for you as if you were
taking care of yourself as if you cared
for yourself well what would that look
like
you know let's say just for the sake of
argument if you figured out where you
work that you could have what would be
best for you well what is that I bet you
never asked people don't ask and so life
comes out them like random snakes and
they sort of fend them off and life goes
by and things don't work out the way
people expected them to but a huge part
of that is they didn't know where they
were but they wouldn't look or didn't
know that they should look ignorant
willful blindness right two great
catastrophes
and they never figured out where they
wanted to go or why now there's a
problem with figure out where you want
to go and the problem is is that you
make your conditions for failure clear
to yourself and people don't like that
so if you keep yourself in the fog then
you can't tell when you screwed up now
that isn't so good because you're still
screwing up you're just too blind self
blind to notice although in the short
term not less painful if you make your
criteria for success razor-sharp then
you know every time you screw up but
that's great because then you could fix
it you could either repair the the
behavioral it adequacy or the conceptual
inadequacy that you're using as a tool
in that situation or maybe you could
adjust your dam plan either way you can
fix it and so okay so you're living in
one of these bloody things and you might
as well it seems to me you might as well
make it the best one you could live in
because you don't have anything better
to do now if you don't do that if you
don't do it consciously and this is what
the psychoanalyst pointed out is that
you have enumerable quasi autonomous
subsystems that make you up that will
generate stories impulsively and you'll
just act them out and you know that
because you watch yourself over two
weeks and you think Jesus I did a lot of
stupid things in the last two weeks and
you think why it's because you're a
random you're a collection of somewhat
random quasi autonomous personality
units and lacking a leader they're just
going to fire off whenever they want you
know first you're hungry then you're
thirsty then you want to go to bed with
your wife you know then you want to
sleep in and you want to tell your boss
off and you want to curse at the guy
that cuts you off in traffic it's like
you're kind of like a two-year-old
you know just it's one emotional frame
after another vying for dominance
there's no overarching hierarchy and
there's no king at the top and so you
know we already talked about pyramids of
competence and what's supposed to be at
the top is you want to bring all those
things together we understand this
neurologically I'll show you some of
that in a little bit we understand this
neurologically how
how this maps in some sense right on to
the neural structure of your being you
want to put something in control and the
thing that you should put in control is
the bloody thing that pays attention and
learns right everything else in the
hierarchy should be subordinate to the
thing that pays attention and learns and
you could think well that's that's the
message of the idea of logos that's for
sure because logos is partly attention
and partly communication and you learn a
lot by communicating with others okay so
you need to know where you are just like
your GPS which is about the closest
thing we have to an intelligent
cybernetic system those GPS is in your
cars those bloody things are pretty
smart because they can they know where
you are they know where you're going and
if you go off course they recalculate
your route it's like those things are
damn near alive that's so close to
intelligence it's and you can tell that
because they act intelligently they
solve problems continually so you need
and this is a cybernetic model by the
way and cybernetic models for the models
on which the GPS systems were based so
it's not accidental so you need to know
where you are and you need to know where
you're going and then the next thing you
need to know is how it is that you're
going to act move your body how you're
going to propel yourself through time
and space to transform this into that
and so ok and then we can we can make
that a little bit more complex because
it's a bit too simple so we'll do this
so it isn't exactly that you live in one
of these it's that you live in a nested
hierarchy of these and you could think
of this as your own internal patriarchy
that's a good way of thinking about it
and maybe it could be a tyrant or maybe
it could be something that gives you
security and functional autonomy and
hopefully that's the one you go for it
but it's a battle you know because a
little bit of tyranny exists in everyone
and so well so at the very highest level
of analysis that would be the
overarching story maybe you think I'd
like to be a good person or a successful
person or famous person
I think Goods probably a bit better
because you can come up with the
definition of good if you want as long
as it doesn't annoy other people too
badly
because they'll just get in your way and
that won't be helpful so you have to
negotiate it but let's say you're a good
person that's sort of the story at the
top of the hierarchy and then you could
decompose that into your primary roles
maybe you're a good parent maybe you're
a good employer or maybe you're a good
employee maybe you're a good sibling
maybe you're a good child you know those
are major roles that you have in your
life and so you'd say that
what good person is is what's good about
you across all those rules so it's a
it's a it's a higher-order abstraction
from something more concrete and then
you can take the you know the role good
parent and you can say well what is it
that constitutes a good parent and you
might say well a good parent this isn't
exhaustive obviously a good parent has a
good job and takes care of his or her
family and then you might say well what
does it mean to take care of your family
and then you might say well you know you
you can cook the odd meal not too odd
hopefully you can cook the odd meal and
you can play with play with the baby and
then you might say well how do you play
with a baby and then you might say well
you play peek-a-boo with the baby or you
tickle the baby okay well that's what's
a cool there's a cool shift there
because this is all articulated and
conceptual right right down to this
level and then all of a sudden it's your
body because how do you play peekaboo is
a baby you don't like have a chat about
how you play peek-a-boo with a baby
right you go like this it's great fun
you can even do it with older people
they even smile about it right it's
dad's gone and the baby's all shocked to
death about that where to go oh look
he's back you know it's the baby is
playing with the reliability of the
world so it's real intense game for a
baby
like oh no dad god no look he showed up
again oh no he's gone and then bad
smiling to indicate that those brief
flashes into non-existence aren't
existentially terrifying beyond capacity
right and so but the point is is that if
you're playing peek-a-boo with the baby
you're not thinking anymore it's not in
the realm of articulation or abstraction
it's actually something that you're
doing with your body and so to me this
is a nice multistage solution to the
mind-body problem because what happens
is the highest the higher order of
abstraction its articulated and
conceptual but if you decompose it
sufficiently you end up with an actual
action and the action involves the
movement of musculature it's not
something conceptual and one of the
things that's really cool about this
hierarchy is that it has educational
lessons so one of the things you want to
do if you're trying to teach someone
something even yourself is you want to
you want to specify the thing that needs
to be doing at the highest resolution
possible level so I'll give you just a
brief example so let's say I may have we
may be repeating this but it doesn't
matter say you've got a three-year-old
kid and they're in their room is chaos
right this monsters are going to be
coming out under the bed in no time flat
unless that thing room gets some order
in it and so you you tell the kids clean
up the room you know it's a mess and you
leave and you come back and the kids
like throwing Legos everywhere it's
they're not cleaning up and then you
think that's a bad kid that's a bad
theory a because you're going right from
here to here if you want to have a good
fight with someone and destroy them then
that's what you do you don't bother with
the subtleties down here you just go
right from the great for the jugular
it's like you're a bad stupid kid you've
always been that way you're hopeless
there's not a chance of teaching you
anything right and we can that way you
can nail the past the present and the
future all of the same in so you've
always been a terrible person there's no
teaching you and your future is going to
be exactly the same way then the only
thing the person can do if you do that
to them is hit you because that's that's
it there's no there's no coming back
from that you've boxed them completely
in so if you want to have a really
unproductive argument you go right for
this
past present and future you're not a
good person demolish their entire
conceptual structure and expose them
completely naked to chaos it's like
great you won the argument
it's not a good thing to do to your
long-term partner let's say unless you
want them terrified out of this skull
and characterised and their attitude
towards you characterized by non-stop
extreme resentment it's probably not
going to do your love life a hell of a
lot of good for example so with the
three year old maybe what you do is you
say you pick the level of analysis at
which they're actually functioning and
you say and this is something you can do
if you pay attention to a kid and lots
of people won't pay attention to
children because they're terrified of
them they're terrified that they'll do
something wrong with them and or that
the kid won't like them or some damn
thing it's like all you have to do to
get a kid to like you is pay attention
to the kid for like two seconds and the
kid will instantly like you because
attention is so it's such a it's it's
the ultimate currency for children right
they need adult attention because adults
know way more than kids and so they love
attention all you have to do is pay
attention to them they will like you
instantly so they tell the kid you see
that teddy bear kid goes yes then you've
established that the child has mastered
the art of perceiving a teddy bear
because they can say yes it's this
complicated thing man it's like I aged
six months old isn't going to do that
three months old has got the whole teddy
bear identification subroutine and
traumatized so teddy bear yes can you
pick it up yes pat pat pat good work do
you see the hole on that show yes can
you put the teddy bear in that hole yes
go over do that pat pat pat great ok now
we'll do thing number two thing number
three so you're building up the micro
routines of cleaning up the room from
the bottom up right you you're building
it into their body because you're
starting with the things they've already
automatized and building upwards towards
abstraction and so once the kid has all
the micro routines down and maybe
there's I don't know how many micro
routines are there to clean up your room
200 like
a lot but not an infinite number so you
teach them all the micro routines and
then you can say run set of micro
routines which means clean up room and
then they can do it they know what it
means so but you do the building from
the bottom up and lots of times when
you're arguing with someone that you
live with and hypothetically loved
although those two things are hard to
get together in the same relationship
what you want to do is assume is assume
stupidity before you assume total in
total malevolence that's that's that's a
good rule of thumb for establishing
peace so maybe if your partner won't do
something
well maybe it's there's something going
on up here but you might want to assume
to begin with they actually just don't
know how to do it and you need to
decompose it so maybe there's a way you
want to be greeted when you come home
because you're going to come home every
day probably and maybe that's a five
minute interaction or a 10 minute
interaction so that's an hour a week or
four hours a month or 50 hours a year or
one solid work week of coming home
interactions right all you have to do is
get 50 interactions like that right and
you've got your relationships sorted out
that's something that's really worth
thinking about so that's it there's you
just don't have that much time right get
the meals sorted out that's about five
hours a day get your sleeping time
Arrangements sorted out get the
fundamental interactions that you repeat
with your partner worked out voluntarily
and negotiated you're going to cover 80%
of your life that way and then it can
just run as a routine and that's really
helpful and if you don't do that
consciously especially because our roles
have fragmented and most of the
traditional rules have disappeared and
so nobody knows who the hell is supposed
to do what in the kitchen for example so
nobody does anything except and
fight make wretched meals or or buy or
buy fast food or some something like
that so you know the alternative to that
catastrophic failure or continual
resentment and fighting is to rebuild
the structures from the bottom up using
consensus and negotiation and you can do
that so that you can think of that as
the patriarchal structure that's a good
one
and I mean it's partly psychological
because these are things you do as a
person but it's also partly political
economic and sociological because while
you're doing each of these things you're
also doing them in a way that's socially
hopefully not just socially acceptable
but actually socially desirable and so
that's that's the decomposition and the
reason that this keeps chaos at bay is
because it isn't because your belief
systems keep chaos at bay it's not that
abstract it's that if you do things
right do these things right then
terrible things happen to you with less
frequency and that's not the psyche like
it's partly psychological because maybe
you don't fight as much maybe not
anxious as much maybe you're not as
depressed but a lot of it's just
practical if you just if you you know if
your kid doesn't leave his skateboard on
the stairs then you don't break your
neck as often and that's not just
psychological that's actually a good
thing not to break your neck so often
and so this structure isn't merely
something that keeps things at bay
psychologically okay so here's a here's
another look at a hierarchy of a
narrative the structure that keeps chaos
at bay and this is maybe the hierarchy
that I engage in when I'm writing and
I'm doing all these things at the same
time that's that's what's cool you know
like that when I ask student what are
you doing when you write an essay it's
like well that's hard question right
it's like well you're fast and important
question that's the first thing you
should do if you're writing an essay
then you're paying attention to the
words and the phrases in the sentences
and the sentence relationship between
the sentences within the paragraphs and
the paragraph relationships to one
another within the essay and then they
ask these relevance to the class and the
class is relevance to your life and what
the essay bleeds out across your entire
life and so if I'm writing something
well obviously at the most highest
resolution level of analysis I'm
actually moving my fingers on the
keyboard and moving my eyes back and
forth on the screen that's where the
mind meets the body but then I'm trying
to formulate a sentence and so I try to
think up a good sentence that's that's
nailing what I am trying to formulate
and then I try to pick it apart and I do
that a bunch of ways
take the sentence and I put it on
another page and then a rate like 10
different variants of the sentence and
see if I can get a better variant and
then I try to think of ways that it's a
stupid sentence to see if I can you know
put a pry bar underneath it and loosen
it up and if I can't do anything if I
can't manage that then I keep the
sentence that I've got and then I do
that with ten sentences in a paragraph
and I make sure the sentences are all
arranged properly in the paragraph the
same way by rewriting a bunch of
different variants of it and trying to
get the word right in a phrase right and
the sentence right and the sentence
order right and the paragraph order
right and I can tell what it's right
enough because I can't make it any
better it doesn't mean it's right it
just means I can't improve it and so I
get to the point where if I'm writing a
paragraph and I write a variant and I
can't tell if the variance is any better
and it might be worse than I'm done I'd
hit the limit of my intellectual
capacity and it's time to move on but
then but you know that it isn't like the
essay that I'm writing let's say has a
boundary it's tightly drawn around the
essay because there's a reason I'm
writing the damn essay and that would be
well I'm trying to I'm turned write a
whole manuscript hopefully I'm trying to
address an important problem because why
would I be doing it otherwise I mean
that'd be kind of pointless and maybe
that's part of my role as a scientist
and that's a subset of my role as a
professor and then that's a subset of my
role as a productive citizen and then
that's a subset of my role of someone
who confronts the unknown see and that's
why the logos is the thing that's at the
top of the hierarchy that's how the
hierarchy should be structured is that
everything else should be see because
you have a structure do you think well
what should the structure be subordinate
to and then the answer should be
something like the structure should be
subordinate to the process that
generates the structure or the structure
should be subordinate to the process
that generates and maintains the
structure well obviously how could it be
any other way unless the structure is
perfect with the in which case you
dispensed with the thing that generates
it and improves it but then you're a
totalitarian it's like hey we got the
answer it's like no you don't people are
still suffering and they're still dying
you don't have the damn answer
and so maybe you have an answer that
means that there isn't quite as much
suffering and dying as there could be
but there's plenty of road to be
traveled yet and so it all makes perfect
sense that all of this should be should
be nested within this highest sigh think
of it sort of as the highest order of
moral striving and then that also gives
you moral hierarchy that's the most
important thing we do that with honor
speech you do that with the tension and
honest speech that's how you do that and
you don't sacrifice that to any of this
because if you do then then you're
hurting your soul it's there's this idea
in the New Testament that the sin
against the Holy Ghost is the one sin
that can't be forgiven no one knows what
the hell that means maybe it doesn't
mean anything
but I think this is what it means is
that because this process generates all
this if you violate that process then
there's no hope for you because that's
the process by which you improve
yourself and everyone else to everything
else so if you decide you're not going
to engage in that it's like well there's
no fixing that because you've blown
apart your relationship with the thing
that does the fixing and so ok and so
that's how you keep chaos at bay and so
part of that is structural right because
you know how to do these things more or
less it's part of your skill set if you
happen to be a writer you could build
one of these for a plumber it doesn't
doesn't make any difference really
although the outside things should be
the same which is I think partly why in
in the judeo-christian tradition there's
the assumption that people are
fundamentally equal before God and what
that means is that well they should be
nested everyone regardless of their
particularly particularities as
individuals their highest order function
is that they do it in whatever manner
they can manage and that's an
extraordinarily valuable or maybe the
most extraordinarily valuable
sociological political and economic
function and so that's why people are
valuable it's like we have this faculty
to continually generate improvements
to the structure that we jointly inhabit
great that gives us it's so cool because
that gives us a fundamental unity we've
got the highest order of analysis with
with the room for as much diversity as
you can possibly manage right because it
actually turns out that the more the sub
structures differ the better because
then you know you can be doing something
different than me that would be good
because if we were doing the same thing
then it's just duplication of labor if
we could agree on the higher order
principle and then specialize that the
lower order levels it's like that's you
get to have your cake and eat it too and
that doesn't happen very often so so and
so then another rule of thumb is if
you're trying to solve a problem solve
it at this level highest resolution
level possible before you dare move up
dare move up the hierarchy because the
as you move up the abstraction hierarchy
the probability that you'll make a
catastrophic error while attempting to
fix the problem radically increases
because abstraction is very very
powerful and so you want to be very
careful I mean we saw that when you know
when the you know when the mortgage
market crashed the reason it crashed was
because of strange use of derivatives
and derivatives are like higher order
abstractions in the financial world and
derivatives give you tremendous
financial leverage and power with huge
risk and so the upside is massive
absolutely massive because you can
multiply your earnings but the downside
is complete bloody catastrophe and so
part of what I would say an intelligent
conservative ethos is is solve the
problem at the highest level of
resolution the highest level most local
level of resolution it's safer and it's
more likely to actually produce a
solution ok now so now you're in your
plan now we're simplified again just to
one little map right but all those other
things are nested in there and so what
happens to you as you stroll merrily on
your way through life well what happens
is that as you're moving from point A to
point B you encounter things and people
think that what they encounter are
but that's not the case first of all
most of the things that you encounter
many of the things are actually other
people and they're not objects they're
too damn complex and even apart from the
social world the things that you
encounter aren't objects they seem to be
something more like tools or obstacles
and I don't mean that we see objects and
turn them into tools or obstacles I mean
that we see tools and obstacles because
what happens is that when you array
yourself towards a goal then the world
transforms itself into things that get
in the way of that goal and things that
three things things are get in the way
of the goal things those are things you
don't like things that facilitate your
movement towards the goal those are
things that you like and the irrelevant
things and mostly you want irrelevant
things because there's just too damn
many things so the category of
irrelevant is one you really like so
most the thing most of everything is
irrelevant if you have a good plan a few
things are good because they move you
forward and some other things are not so
good you want to go around the not so
good things if you can manage them
unless you like to run head forth into
like brick walls which is not
particularly so learning experience but
I would repeat it too many times you
want you want the world to array itself
as a set of we could say tools now what
happens is that you have this perceptual
system that's mediated by dopamine it's
the same system that cocaine activates
or methamphetamine or the drugs that
people really like to take and it's the
dopaminergic system that responds with
positive emotion to indications that
you've encountered something that will
facilitate your movement towards a goal
and that's really important to know
because people tend to think that
they're happy because they achieve goals
and that's not true what's true it
because as soon as you achieve a goal
then you have a problem which is what's
the next goal and that's actually a big
problem you encounter that as soon as
you graduate from university for example
it's right
I made this joke before the graduation
day here's like king of the university
hierarchy undergraduate hierarchy day
after you're unemployed potential
Starbucks employee right so it's like so
obviously the accomplishment per se as a
source of reward is is problematic
because when you accomplish you run the
frame to its
and then you have the problem of needing
a new frame so that's a problem but if
what you're encountering instead are
things that will move you along your way
it's like hey that's great and that's
where you get your positive motivation
and so that's really thinking that's so
much we're thinking about you can think
about that for a year and that wouldn't
even be enough to think about it because
here's what it means it means in some
sense that the Buddhists are right with
their claim about Maya
mnya which means that people live in an
illusion and what they mean by that is
well you have goal whatever your goal is
and that goal gives relevance to the
world and you could change the relevance
of the world in a snap just by changing
your goal you can do that and so then
you think well it's sort of an illusion
because you can just change it now you
don't want to push that line of
argumentation too far because even if
the specific point can be changed the
fact that you're in one of these frames
cannot be changed and so you have to be
in a frame although you get to pick the
frame so there's still an absolute there
which is that you have to be in the
frame and that is not a trivial absolute
it's a very it's a very major absolute
so then you think okay all of your
positive emotion is going to be
experienced in relationship to the goal
well then we think well you could use
some positive emotion it's a good thing
positive emotion inhibits anxiety and
disappointment and frustration and pain
it does all that technically it does
that that's why a football player with a
broken thumb who wants to score a
touchdown can go out there you know play
the football game even though it's a
kind of an arbitrary goal right it's
like really you're going to go out there
and like risk your hand to fire a
pigskin through some some polls it's
like well you could say the same sort of
cynical thing about most of the things
that people do but you can't say the
silikal thing about the fact that they
have to do things so you have a you have
a point you have your aim you have your
ambition and then that's what turns the
world into a potentially positive place
and here's the kicker this is so cool
the higher they aim the more the
positive emotion so that's that you
think well why should I bother you
why should I bother doing something
lofty and difficult it's like because
it's worth it that's why because the
alternative is stupid suffering because
really really because what happens is
like you don't need a framework in order
to suffer you can just lay there day
after day and suffer right that's the
easy that's the default condition if you
don't have a lofty ambition then you
suffer miserably and the reason for that
is life is really complex
short finite full of suffering and
Beyond you and so you can just lay there
and think about that and it's horrible
and so that's not helpful it's just not
useful and so you know people often say
life is meaningless it's like no it's
not that's wrong because it was
meaningless that would be easy you could
just sit there and do nothing and it
would matter right it'd be like you were
look like you're like a lobotomized
sheep it's just irrelevant but that
isn't what happens when people say that
life has no meaning that isn't what they
mean what they mean is I'm suffering
stupidly and intensely and I don't know
what to do about it well the suffering
is meaningful it's just not the kind of
meaning you want so how do you get out
of that you adopt you you note the
baseline of suffering which is very very
very very high and then you say to
yourself okay I need to do something
that justifies that and that's not so
easy because it's the baseline for
suffering is high if you're going to
make something of yourself let's say so
that it's worthwhile to exist in the
world then you have to do is you have to
aim at something that's so well
structured that you can say yeah
earthquakes cancer death of my family
dissolution of my goals ultimate
futility of life and the heat death of
the universe hey it doesn't matter it's
worth it
alright so now here's an here's another
complicating factor so I said well
there's three things that you can run
into when you're going about
your your goal and I would say if you're
going to farm a goal it's going to form
a plan look about three to five years
out in the future because beyond that
you get something called combinatorial
explosion and it means that there's so
many variables you just can't predict so
there's not that much point looking out
20 years because like what the hell you
know what's going to happen in 20 years
nothing three years maybe you've got
maybe you can chart a course to three
years five years something like that so
that's not a bad segment of time to to
consider and then consider what your
life would have to be like in order for
it to be worthwhile for you knowing also
what you're going to be like if it isn't
worthwhile for you and what you're going
to be like if it isn't worthwhile for
you is Caine that's what you're like
because that's what that story's about
because Abel's the guy who has a goal
and is making the proper sacrifices and
Cain is the person for whom by his own
fault at least in part things aren't
working out for and so the default for
not doing this is something like
building resentment bitterness with an
underlying what would you call it flavor
enhancer of murderous resentment
something like that which you will act
out in the world which people act out in
the world all the time and it's no
wonder because without this without
something lofty pulling you along then
the baseline is stupid suffering and you
know if you take an analog and you just
chained in the backyard you know you put
a collar on it that's too tight so it
chafes all the time and it can't even
bark and you know there's just dirt
around it it's too goddamn hot out in
the Sun and maybe don't give it enough
water you know it's not going to be very
happy dog it's basic conditions misery
well the same applies to people so all
right so you're on your way to see you
remember the you've all probably watched
Pinocchio or know about it one of the
things that happens it's really cool in
Pinocchio is that when Geppetto decides
that he wants his puppet to be a genuine
autonomous being
he wishes upon a star it's a very
strange thing but everybody just
swallows it because we don't notice when
we're swallowing things that are that
are completely preposterous you know
it's this animated puppeteer which is
not a star that is puppet is going to
become real and everybody know it's
their head and goes oh you have that big
sense it's like no it doesn't it doesn't
make any sense at all but it doesn't
matter it doesn't make this sort of
sense that we normally associate with
sense it makes a kind of meta sense and
everybody understands it so this is what
Geppetto is doing is he's elevating his
eyes above the horizon so out of the
realm of the worldly let's say to the
transcendent and the transcendent will
say for all intents and purposes you can
see the transcendent spread above you in
the heaven that arches over us it gets
close enough for our purposes and
there's a star there and a star of
something that's eternal that shines in
the darkness and so Geppetto makes an
agreement with the transcendent he says
look I'm willing to do whatever it takes
that my creation becomes autonomous well
that's exactly this situation that you
want to set up for yourself is like okay
you've got to figure out what star
you're going to orient yourself by and
you have to ask yourself like no one's
ever asked you okay if you have the
choice to make your life worth living
what's your price what do you need just
find out first of all you just ask
you'll tell yourself like you'll be
afraid because if I'll never get that
it's like don't lower your sights a
little bit then you know don't ask for a
80-foot super yacht in like six months
that just means you're stupid you know
as it doesn't mean you're not you know
first of all it's not going to make you
happy anyways you know it's just not
it's not it's not wise you're asking you
supposed to be asking yourself this
question like you're someone you care
about so you imagine you're talking to
some 12 year old kid that you kind of
like thank God it wouldn't be so bad if
this twelve-year-old kid at a decent
life so you - it's like it wouldn't be
so bad the universe wouldn't mind if you
had a decent life if there is little
less suffering on your part especially
if you didn't you know foist it off on
other people if there's a little less
suffering on your part and you made
things a little better everywhere you
went it's like the universe would
probably
okay with that so you could I think you
could get away with it if you're sort of
quiet about it and so ask yourself okay
so then once you've established your
your target you know where you are then
you know what's good for you because
that moves you along and that happens at
a perceptual level you don't have to
think about it anymore and the
experimental literature and that's
already quite clear so for example if I
specify that podium as the target for my
action you know then I'm happy when I'm
walking towards it because there it is
and everything cooperating really nicely
but if I specify going to the exit sign
that you guys can't see that's the that
that this is an obstacle in the front of
then as soon as I specify that then
that's an annoying obstacle and that's
precognitive it just happens immediately
it happens instantaneously and so it
really is the case that you you you're
you're being manifests itself inside
these frames and so what's so cool about
that is you can change the frame it
doesn't mean you can like juggle planets
or anything like that but it does give
you quite a scope of what I'm trammeled
action within the world and if the frame
isn't working out then you can tweak it
or sometimes you have to make a major
adjustment in it whatever you don't have
to stick to the damn thing like it's the
ideology that you're going to die for
it's a tentative plan it's a work in
progress and it's nuts with the future
authoring program one of the things I
recommend for people is that they should
do it badly because you're not going to
get it right anyways but a reasonable
plan is way better than no plan plus a
reasonable plan is a plan that has built
into it the processes that will enable
the plan to get better as you implement
it so you just start with AB reasonable
plan so you don't have to worry about
whether it's correct it's not correct
doesn't matter it's better than nothing
that's the issue so okay so you've got
the world parsed up into things that
make making you happy when you look at
them things that get in the way that
produce negative emotion and then a
whole host of irrelevant things because
almost everything is irrelevant and
that's where all the chaos is hiding the
chaos is hiding in what's irrelevant
and so and that's very interesting
observation because since the chaos is
virtually infant I think surreal
questions where the hell do you put it
well you put it in what you ignore and
you can ignore it as long as it isn't
actively interfering with your movement
forward you can assume that it's that it
doesn't matter that it in matter that it
doesn't matter same thing alright so
here's the kicker there's one more class
of things that you can run into along
the way and this is where the chaos
breaks through so let's say you're
moving from point A to point B and
something that you don't expect
Oh curves and it gets in the way so
let's say that you're living with
someone and maybe you kind of like them
you're not married so you don't like
them that much because otherwise you'd
ask them to marry you but anyways and so
high quarter of youth is looking for
something better and 3/4 of view is half
satisfied something like that and then a
person because we're ambivalent about
such things and then the person you
discover or the person announces that
they'd be having an affair okay so then
how are you supposed to respond
emotionally to that well the part of you
that wasn't all that committed to the
relationship is kind of exhilarated by
that and then the 3/4 of you that's half
satisfied is hurt and and you're going
to exploit that part for sure in the
ensuing discussions and not mention the
oh that's kind of exciting that you you
know betrayed me that way so so but the
point is is that you that's a whole now
what's happened as a whole has you have
this structure that you're walking on
like ice like the thin ice that you're
skating on and now there's a hole in it
and the hole we don't even know how deep
the hole is but you know there's a hole
there and so now you're anxious about it
though maybe also a little bit excited
because god only knows what's down there
but but you don't know what to do with
that hole because it could spread very
badly on you it could be that you know
the whole relationship was a facade and
that all your relationships have been
facade facade
and that the reason that is is because
you're so damn shallow that it's
impossible for you to have a
relationship that isn't just a facade
and that's partly because you don't pay
any attention to other people and it's
also partly because your malevolent and
selfish so that's a nasty thing to
discover or maybe that's the sort of
person that you're attracting which
would make sense actually if that's the
sort of person that you are and so so
there are certain things that you can
encounter that basically unglue you and
what happens is that those moments of
being unglued travel up that entire
hierarchy of presuppositions it's like
because the one of the logical
conclusions to being betrayed in a
relationship is that you are that you're
truly a bad person now another equally
logical conclusion is that the person
that you're with is really a bad person
and another logical conclusion is all
people are truly bad people you know I
mean it in microwaves out in microwaves
you can't trust anyone you can't trust
women you can't trust men you can't
trust human beings you can't trust
yourself the whole place is a
catastrophe it's a nightmare well then
you can fall through into chaos now the
way your body responds to that when some
or maybe you know you're supposed to be
getting a promotion at work that's good
you're all chipper about the promotion
at work and you you walk into your
boss's office because he or she wants to
see you and they say wow you know we've
reviewed your performance over the last
few years and your performance has been
somewhere between mediocre and decent
and we're downsizing and see you later
that's not a raise or a promotion that's
for sure
not so whole that you fall into and the
question is well what do you make of
that right how do you frame that how do
you take that emergent chaos and make
habitable order out of you don't know is
the whole capitalist system rotten to
the core I mean that's a convenient
explanation under those circumstances
that's for sure were you working for a
psychopathic son of a did you make
the wrong choice in university and was
that your father's fault because you
never did what you want or was it your
fault for not standing up to them or is
it a dying
industry or is maybe this a wake-up call
that you should go do something else
that you've been waiting to do you know
that you've actually wanted to do your
whole life and that's why you're doing
such a miserable job at your current
occupation because you're bitter and
resentful about the fact that you never
did what you want you don't know it's
all of those things at once and that's
very stressful because all of those
things at once is too many things and
that's the reimburse of chaos that's the
flood that's the return to the beginning
of the cosmos that's another way that
it's been represented mythologically
it's that you voyage all the way back to
the beginning of the cosmos when there's
nothing but undifferentiated chaos and
that's what you're confronting and maybe
it's too much for you and it's often it
is I mean that that can really that can
be traumatizing it can hurt your brain
you know it's just too much for you to
bear but it doesn't matter you're stuck
with it and so how do you respond to
that well some of it is catastrophic
negative emotion you freeze and that's
protective and maybe you don't even want
to move you don't want to bloody well
get out of bed for a week and that's
because your body is reacting as if the
bedroom floor is covered with snakes and
the best thing for you to do is just not
move just freeze not a pleasant
situation to be in because it's you're
hyper aroused very very physiologically
demanding and there's zero about if it's
productive except maybe the snakes won't
see you but they've already seen you so
that isn't helping very well so you've
got all this undifferentiated negative
emotion anxiety fear hurt anger guilt
shame emotional pain the whole plethora
of catastrophes and then maybe on the
other side lurking down there is thank
God I'm done without you oughta just
bloody well hate it I dragged myself off
to work every day and there's a little
part of my soul that's a goddamn happy I
finally got fired that I can hardly
stand it you know maybe you don't even
admit that to yourself because well that
would mean that all that time you spent
at the job was just some cost you're
deluding yourself the whole time I mean
isn't an interesting thing to consider
though sometimes if you're in the
unpleasant circumstance of having to
fire someone
you know sometimes firing someone is the
best thing that can happen to them which
doesn't mean that you should go out and
like enjoy it
although I have met very disagreeable
people who actually enjoyed firing
people I'll tell you a story about that
at some point because it's quite
interesting but you know sometimes if
someone's just limping along in their
job and doing it as miserably and
wretchedly as they possibly can imagine
the best thing you can do to them for
them is to say you know you're failing
at this and and that doesn't necessarily
mean that you would have to be failing
it absolutely everything else in the
entire world so maybe you should just
accept the dam failure and go off and
try something new and I mean that's
terrifying for people and I know they
hate it and all that but but but
sometimes it's better than the
alternative which is just slow torturous
death so here's a funny way of looking
at it so let's say you fall right in for
that hole that's underneath any
everything and you've hit an anomaly
that you don't understand you say what's
that anomaly made out of exactly I know
that's a strange way of thinking about
it you know because it's not what you
could say we'll just go along with that
it's a metaphor
what's that anomaly made out it well
here's a way of thinking but it's made
out of spirited matter and here's why
this is something I learned in part from
Piaget said what's made out of matter
because of course that's the world
matter and the world is also what
matters and so that's kind of a nice
duality there but it's made out of
spirit because when you encounter
something anomalous and go down the
rabbit hole when you go into the
underworld that's underneath everything
that you've relied on you learn things
down there so what's down there is
information and that's now it's maybe
way more information than you want but
it is information it's information and
what can what can you do with the
information you can inform yourself with
the information right you could put
yourself in formation with the
information that's helpful too and so
and you think well you you're a psyche
if you're not a spirit it depends on you
know whether you're a materialist or not
but at least we can say that you're a
psyche the question is what's your
psyche made up well it's obviously go
out of material some
right but the matter happens to be
arrayed in a particular order and that's
an information order and so when you
fall into the underworld that's
underneath everything and you encounter
that latent information then what you
can do is enhance your psyche you can
grow your spirit because what you do is
you take the new information and you
incorporate it that's like eating the
Apple that out of an EVE it you
incorporate that and that makes more of
you and that's not a metaphorical or a
metaphysical proposition it's not to say
nothing other than well that's what
happens when children learn you think
what happens charles's three has a
pretty low resolution representation of
the world and is a fairly low resolution
human being got all the constituent
elements there but isn't differentiated
in any tremendous manner that's all
still to come in the future and so what
if the child do explore what do they
explore things they don't understand
that's where the information is because
you already understand what you
understand there's no information there
you go where there where you don't
understand that's where the information
is and out of that information you
generate a higher resolution world and
you generate a higher resolution self
and so out of the combat with the
underlying dragon of chaos you generate
spirit and matter and that's what you do
when you go down into the underworld so
if it doesn't kill you or if it doesn't
make you wish you were dead which you
probably will but there's a bunch of you
that has to die down there anyway so
maybe that's not such a bad thing
because if you had this relationship
that ended in betrayal then there's
something that's just not exactly right
right there's something that wentz and
the reason I'm saying that think well
that's kind of moralistic it's like
actually I don't mind being moralistic
in case you haven't noticed but but
that's not it's not a fair comment
because you're playing this stupid game
it's like you live with someone in
fidelity that's the game right you've
decided the rules with the game comes a
morality the morality are the rules of
the game well then the thing collapses
into infidelity it's like well you
played the game wrong or it was the
wrong game one of those two you it's one
of those two you pick the damn game and
having picked the game you can't
say well no those aren't the rules it's
like yeah yeah if you pick the game you
pick the rules and if you fail at
complying with the rule then you fail
now you could say well I could pick a
different game it's like I don't care
how you solve the problem you're still
stuck with the problem it's a moral
problem fundamentally and it might take
some major-league retooling to to fix it
so you're at point a trying to get to
point B that's not working out you hit
an anomaly you're not getting the point
B that's for sure
your medical school student you write
your MCATs which is a test you have to
write to go to medical school you get
25th percentile I don't know who you are
but you're not a pre-med student and
maybe you never were right and that's
the rub man and so who the hell are you
you don't know collapse down here into
this motivational conflict this place of
motivation unemotional uncertainty and
tremendous information right it's a
place of transformation it's the Phoenix
that burns it's the burning part of the
Phoenix that burns it's it's the journey
to the underworld it's the journey to
hell it can really be a journey to hell
because you may find out that the reason
that your partner betrayed you or that
you didn't get your damn promotions
because there's seriously something
wrong with you and you know it and I
don't just mean that you don't know what
you're doing I mean that there's 25
percent of you that is seriously aiming
at things not being good and so you fall
into the underworld and you find out
that oh god I just got exactly what I
was aiming for or I got exactly what the
worst part of me was aiming for and that
worst part that's something to clean up
and that's not going to be easy because
it's got it tooks to me like something
something ferocious something seriously
ferocious and I've been toying with it
for a very long time and maybe I can't
even detach it anymore and so that's not
so fun and you see people like that in
psychotherapy very frequently or you see
them wandering around on the streets
like absolute catastrophic former shells
of themselves you know because they've
hit the underworld and they ended up in
hell and there's no getting out
so those are the people you tend to give
a wide berth to when you walk down the
street so there you are down in
underworld right back where the latent
information exists and just too much of
it and that's this it's the same thing
it's the same thing and that's why the
Adam and Eve story is archetypal right
because we're always ingesting something
new that knocks us into a new state of
self-consciousness and it's always a
catastrophic demolition of our current
of our previous paradise insufficient as
that paradise was something comes along
to destroy it and knocks the slats out
of our life and that's a voyage to the
underworld out of the walled garden into
chaos and so what is all of that well
there's lots of ways of construing it
it's a it's a frame transformation
there's a walled city it's got a hole in
it because all walled cities have holes
in them right because everything's
imperfect and that's where the chaos
comes up and then maybe you go out there
like a hero to fight the chaos and to
reestablish the frame that's what you're
supposed to do and maybe you free some
information while you're doing that or
maybe you establish your relationship
and so that's the journey frame damage
chaos voluntary confrontation
reconstitution of the world and that's
that's human existence and hopefully
it's not just a little linear it's it's
stepwise right is that the you that
emerges as a consequence of your latest
catastrophe is everything that you were
before plus something more and that
actually constitutes what you might
describe as measurable progress right
and that's another argument against
moral relativism because if you can do
everything that you could do before and
you can do some more things we could
just define that as better it's not a
bad definition and then we have
up it's like what you're trying to do is
to differentiate the world and
differentiate yourself and every time
you undergo one of these revolutions
then hopefully both of those things
happen and then there's a moral to that
story too which is do it voluntarily
and maybe do it don't wait for it to
happen catastrophic ly keep your eyes
open and when something goes a little
bit wrong that you could fix fix it
don't say no that doesn't matter maybe
it does matter maybe it is matter maybe
it's exactly the matter out of which you
should be built
maybe it's the matter out of which the
world should be built and if part of you
is telling you it matters what it means
is that that part is telling you that
there's something there that you need to
engage with that's what it means for
something to matter I really get out of
the kick a kick out of the word matter
because it's got these two weird
meanings right there's the matter that
everything is made out of the
materialists think everything is made
out of and that's just dead matter and
then there's the matter that life is
made out of which is what matters and
now and then you're moving through life
and something matters it's calling to
you and that's the unrevealed world
trying to reveal itself to you and all
you have to do is allow it to reveal
itself to you and then maybe what
happens is that a minor shifted
shape is all that has to happen to you
you don't have to burn right down to the
bloody egg and and hatch out you know as
a newborn maybe you can just repair a
little bit of something that's gone
wrong with you and so you can undergo a
sequence of continual micro deaths
instead of waiting for the bloody
catastrophe that might send you so far
down that you'll never recover and all
you have to do is attend to what matters
and your whole nervous system is it's
doing this for you you've got a goal
something happens it matters so what are
you supposed to do with that you're
supposed to you're supposed to fix it
you're supposed to engage with it that's
why it's calling out to you as if it
matters it's saying there's an
indeterminate part of the world here
that wants to manifest itself into fully
articulated being and it's calling to
you to do that
and if you ignore it then it accumulates
and if accumulates it turns into the
dragon of chaos and then it waits until
you're not at your best and then it eats
you and that's the alternative so that
seems like a bad plan unless you like
being lunch meat so so that's a long
introduction to Noah
but you need it you know because you
can't understand the story otherwise and
so because that's what the story is
about and now we can go through the
story relatively rapidly although it
doesn't look like we'll go through all
of it tonight
okay so we'll start with the next
section of Genesis and this is
immediately after Cain and Abel and
there's a short story to begin with just
a fragment I called it Giants of the
earth and it came to pass when men began
to multiply on the face of the earth so
this is after Cain and Abel that and
daughters were born unto them that the
sons of God saw the daughters of men
that they were fair and took them wives
of all which they chose and the Lord
said my spirit shall not always strive
with man for that he is also flesh yet
his days will be 120 years there were
giants in the earth in those days and
also after that when the sons of God
came in unto the daughters of men and
they bare children to them the same
became mighty men which were of old men
of renown now there's been all sorts of
attempts to interpret those few rather
jumbled lines but I see it as a
reflection of did a classic development
of hero mythology which is there and
this is sort of nostalgia for the past
one of the things Mircea Eliade a--
pointed out was that what happens to
human memory in preliterate cultures
because nothing is written down is that
what needs to be preserved gets
amalgamated and so imagine that you have
a culture that's based on fishing let's
say so you have to be a good fisherman
you know and are human beings you use
simple tools to fish are unbelievably
good fishermen they know every bloody
thing you can possibly imagine about
fish because otherwise they die so it's
really important that they learn
everything about fish and maybe they've
been fishing for like 13,000 years or
something like that so there's a lot of
accumulated knowledge and so then the
question is well who taught mankind how
to fish and the answer is fragments of
individuals across history but not there
you know remember the damn fragments you
put them all together into the amalgam
of
the heroic fisherman you know the guy
who established the pattern for proper
fishing whatever that pattern happens to
be one of the patterns might be don't
take all the damn fish because there
won't be any for the next year or
something like that but all those
fragments of discovery get amalgamated
into heroes of the past and then what
you do if you're a fisherman is you act
out the heroic fishermen of the past and
so the idea that there were men of
renown or heroes in the past is just a
fragmentary what would you call it's
just a fragment of that sequence of
ideas that back in the past the remove
mighty human beings who established the
proper patterns of being and they were
the sons of God who took the daughters
of men to life now and it's interesting
too because we do know that the more
confident men are disproportionately
likely to leave offspring so it's a
perfectly reasonable way of formulating
the circumstance onto the flood this is
from Virgil a leotta who wrote a book
called the history of religious ideas
which I would strongly recommend it to
three volume set it's quite readable and
it's brilliant it's brilliant I I really
like it and this is what Ritchie Elias
had to say about flood myths as it's
been well known since the compilations
made by our Andre H Hughes neurons JG
Fraser who wrote the Golden Bough the
deluge myth the flood minute is almost
universally disseminated it is
documented on all the continents
although very rarely in Africa
particularly in the desert for
unsurprisingly although and on various
cultural levels a certain number of
variants seem to be the result of
dissemination rather than spontaneous
regeneration let's say first from
Mesopotamia and then from India it is
equally possible that one or several
diluvial catastrophes gave rise to
fabulous narratives but it would be
risky to explain so widespread a myth by
phenomena of which no geological traces
has been found
well Eliot wrote this quite a while ago
I think he wrote that book perhaps in
the 80s maybe in the 70s but since then
there actually has been quite a bit of
evidence
announced in various circles for the
existence of catastrophic floods that
occurred within the relative memory of
human relative human civilization memory
let's say so the West Coast Indians for
example I suppose that's the wrong word
the West Coast I don't know what to say
I know a croc baccala carver who told me
a flood story and they have a story it's
almost identical to the story of Noah
except of course it involves giant
canoes but it's it's the same story they
release if I remember correctly a raven
but Noah releases a raven first and then
it dove once once the flood comes to an
end and and it has a Tower of Babel
issue to the same story so the canoes
are all put together it's not one giant
canoe it's a bunch of canoes all
together be right out the flood and then
the can you separate it and go all over
the world and that's why there are
people all over the world so anyways the
story is very widely disseminated but
you know there were floods in North
America not that long ago so there are
floods you can look up the Missoula
floods 15,000 to 13,000 years ago and
the coracle are people have probably
been on the west coast for something
like thirteen to fourteen thousand years
so and you know you can you can maintain
an oral tradition for a very very long
time you think no but traditional
societies don't change that's where
their traditional and so they have the
same stories over generations they
remember the same stories so when the
Missoula floods which were a consequence
of melting glacial ice discharged up too
they figure there were 55,000 55 of them
between 15,000 and 13,000 years ago
discharged volumes up to 15 times the
volume of the Amazon River so these are
major-league floods and then Sears it
all published a paper in 2008 called
climate change in post-glacial human
disperses in Southeast Asia claiming
that there were multiple floods
particularly affecting Southeast Asia
between 15,000 and 7,000 years ago so
there might Elliott it might be a bit
wrong about the notion that there were
no geological traces of such such
catastrophic flooding but anyways it
doesn't matter because we're still
looking at this from a psychological
perspective and that's fine the majority
of the
lugnut seem in some sense to form part
of the cosmic rhythm the old world
people by a fallen humanity is submerged
under the waters and sometime later a
new world emerges from the aquatic chaos
in large number of variants the flood is
the result of the sins or ritual faults
of human beings sometimes its results
simply from the wish of a divine being
to put an end to mankind the chief
causes lie at once in the sins of men
and the decrepitude of the world it's a
brilliant analysis partly because it
puts it it draws its lovely parallel
between which I mentioned a bit earlier
between the fact that things go wrong
all by themselves but that you can speed
that along by not paying any attention
you know so if you're in a relationship
you know relationship takes an awful lot
of maintenance and you know what it
means
needs to be maintained because you start
developing some distance from the person
that you have the relationship with and
then that starts to become tinged with a
little bit of dislike and hopefully not
contempt but a little bit of dislike and
maybe some some some emotional distance
and you feel that and you think well
it's hard to tell what you think but you
feel that anyways you know that that's
emerged and so then you have a chance at
at that point to repair
whatever's gone wrong and that would
require some retooling on both of your
parts maybe one more one person more
than the other but whatever we would
require a serious discussion like look
I've noticed that this has been
happening and maybe it's you and maybe
it's me and we should probably figure it
out because if it was you that be
convenient and everything but if it was
me then I'd like to fix it because then
it would be fixed and so that's why you
listen to your partner because they
might tell you that there's something
stupid about you that you don't know and
then if you could fix that then you
wouldn't have to be stupid in that way
anymore and it's actually one of the
real useful it's one of the genuinely
useful features of having a partner
because you really want to be stupid and
then continue to repeat your mistakes
ad nauseam for the rest of your life I
know it's more convenient to do that
than to have a you know knockdown drag
them out arguments about just exactly
why you're stupid and how you could fix
it but still it's better to have the
argument
so the chief causes lye at once and the
sins of man in the decrepitude of the
world and the sins there are generally
either acts of commission where people
do things that they know to be wrong or
they fail to do things that they know
would be right doesn't really matter
sins of commission are usually judged
more harshly say within the
judeo-christian tradition but I think
there might be a bit of an error in that
because sins of omission can be a real
catastrophe and so here's the flood idea
you tell me what you think about this so
you know so there's this idea that a
judgmental being will flood you out if
you continue on your wayward ways and
that seems like a little bit of you know
it's one of the examples of Jehova being
a little on the harsh side in the Old
Testament not something that modern
people really approve of so much because
we like our God sort of domesticated
let's put it that way and unfortunately
that isn't how it tends to work but I've
often thought about the reaction in
North America to the hurricane end in
New Orleans because there's two ways of
reading that right one is Mother Nature
has a little fit and sends a hurricane
in to New Orleans and wipes everyone out
and isn't that a catastrophe and isn't
that an example of isn't that example of
our fragility in the force in the face
of natural power but it is another way
of reading it maybe this is unfair but
it'll do for the purpose of illustration
it's like you know the Dutch build dikes
right to keep the ocean back and they're
actually pretty effective at that
because their countries mostly
underwater and it turns out that if you
go to Holland it's actually not
underwater and so their dikes are
working and so the Dutch were very
organized people and they better be
because their country is supposed to be
underwater right so you better be
organized if your country is supposed to
be underwater and so they are very
organized and they have a rule for their
dikes which is they try to estimate the
worst possible oceanic storm that will
come in 10,000 years and make sure that
the dikes will withstand that
well from my reading the Army Corps of
Engineers in New Orleans built the dykes
for a storm every hundred years and
that's not so good because we live about
80 years let's say so that means the
probability that one of those storms is
going to come lip and buy in a lifespan
is pretty damn high and then so that
perhaps wasn't the wisest of planning
especially because some of New Orleans
is actually supposed to be underwater
and then worse you know Mississippi is a
state that's quite well known for its
corruption and so you might also say the
tremendous amount of the money and time
and resources that could have and should
have and was planned to go towards
fixing the problem didn't and so the
hurricane came along and oh my god
wasn't it a natural disaster and the
question is what bloody well makes you
so sure that it was a natural disaster
right because if the infrastructure
would have been maintained and built to
the specifications that were certainly
technically possible and would have
actually been less expensive in the long
run to build and everyone knew it and
the hurricane came along and way build
the city why do you think that's a
natural disaster to me that's a that's a
natural example if you think about it
from a metaphorical perspective of a
judgmental god deciding to use a flood
to teach a moral lesson and you might
say well that's pretty hard what about
all those flood survivors at sea I care
well the whole flood thing was kind of
harsh and so pointing out that there
were steps that could have been taken
and and also that I dealt in the
aftermath have been taken even though
everyone knows now exactly what had
happened is you might consider it a
diagnosis but it's irrelevant because
what I'm what I'm really trying to tell
you is how the mythological stories
would line up on this because you can
tell a story about Mother Nature
manifesting her catastrophe and
potential for tragedy or you can tell
another story of an absolute failure of
the human social structure and the human
individual level
because of the corruption to address a
problem that everyone knew was there and
so that's a good example of how things
how the flood comes when you're not
behaving properly you know and one of
the things that's quite interesting
about the Old Testament and the people
who wrote it is that they always assume
that if the flood comes that meant you
weren't prepared if that's the rule
right that's it's like the a priori
axiom I think you got flooded out hey
you weren't prepared enough how can you
tell well you got flooded out right
that's the evidence and you might say
well that's not very fair it's like fair
isn't the point the point is do you want
to get flooded out again or not because
fair would be well you better figure out
why you got flooded out and fix it so it
doesn't happen again
and that's the moral thing to do when
you're thinking about morality as
walking the path it's most appropriate
to get to the destination that you think
would be the best possible destination
by the mere fact that it exists that is
it lives and produces the cosmos
gradually deteriorate Syd ends by
falling into decay that is the reason
why it has to be recreated in other
words the flood realizes on the macro
cosmic scale what is symbolically
affected during the new year festival
the end of the world and the end of the
sinful humanity in order to make a new
creation possible well that's an
interesting there's a lot of information
packed into those few lines the daily
added wrote because he also had in that
in the Mesopotamian rituals the
Mesopotamians would act out the collapse
of the kingdom into chaos essentially at
the new year's festival it's kind of
what you do when you make resolutions
because like it's a degenerate what
you'd say is our proclivity to make new
year's resolution is sort of a
degenerate ritual and I don't mean that
it's bad I mean that it's the remnants
of something much grander so the idea
was well the Mesopotamians would take
their Emperor outside the city the
walled city and once a year and they
would make a meal and they'd take off
all his king clothes and then they'd
whack them with
if I remember correctly the priest would
do that and then they make him recount
all the ways that he wasn't being a good
Emperor that year he wasn't being a good
Marduk
because that was who he was supposed to
be on earth and that's the guy with eyes
all the way around his head
speaks magic words and transforms chaos
into order
that's what vampire is supposed to do
and so the question would be okay your
Emperor it's like have a little humility
here because you're not God incarnate
you probably made some mistakes can you
think of any ways in the last year that
you didn't take every advantage of every
opportunity you possibly could have to
take some spare chaos and transform it
into a bit of habitable order that's a
good thing to think about well that's
what you're thinking about when you make
a new year's resolution even though you
don't know it it's like well could you
be a better person in the upcoming year
well you can imagine the flood and then
you can set yourself straight and then
you can prepare for it and that means
maybe you can stave it off but it also
means that maybe even if you don't stave
it off you could write it out and that's
actually the story of Noah because what
happens with Noah is that he can see
that things are not good and that
there's a flood coming and God is maybe
letting him know and it says in the
story that Noah walked with God remember
and that's what Adam did before he got
all self-conscious about the whole thing
he walked with God we'll talk about that
more next time but what that would mean
maybe is because Noah was straight and
he put himself together and his familial
relationships were good because it also
says that that his antennae were working
and he could see a little farther into
the future than someone whose vision was
completely obscured by by fog and chaos
and he could tell that things were not
going to go well and so he prepared for
it and because he prepared for it well
then things actually went pretty well
for Noah even though the flood came and
so that's an interesting thing because
that's a that's an indeterminant issue
in human existence how big a hurricane
would it take to wipe out New Orleans
everyone was prepared well the you're
not going to wipe out the Dutch I mean
that's going to be a tough one man
you're going to have to conjure up a
pretty damn big storm to take out their
dikes
well how thoroughly defended to New
Orleans be if nobody in the Municipal
Museum and state governments was corrupt
well end of the hurricane probably
because that's something that we could
clearly deal with we know how to do it
and the same applies in your own life is
that there are floods coming you can
bloody well be sure of that
that's absolutely 100% certain some of
them are going to be personal some of
them are going to be familial some of
they're going to be social and political
and economic it's like are they going to
be catastrophes for you or are you going
to ride them out are you going to
prepare well the first issue might be
well do you have your act together well
enough to see them coming with enough
advance warning so that you can take
proper measures maybe just decide step
it maybe just don't go where the flood
is going to be that's a simple thing but
maybe you don't have that luxury right
and so it is going to be a catastrophe
maybe someone in your family is going to
get really really sick right and maybe
maybe there's just a tiny pathway
through that that everything doesn't
fall apart it doesn't end in divorce it
doesn't end in death it doesn't end in
sorrow doesn't end in catastrophe but
the margin of error is like streaming
down to virtually zero and every
imperfection that you bring to that
situation is going to increase the
probability that that tragedy is going
to turn into something indistinguishable
from hell and that's coming it's coming
your way
absolutely certainly and so then you
might think well since it's coming your
way maybe the best thing to do is to put
yourself together so that when it comes
it can be the least amount of awful
possible so I'll close with the story
this was a very affecting story for me
my mother-in-law had frontal temporal
dementia if she developed it quite young
she was about 55 something like that and
her husband who was very extroverted
man-about-town guy I grew up in a small
town everybody knew him he was
charismatic drank too much charismatic
good businessman quite a remarkable
person a real character but not exactly
a family man even though he provided for
his family very well but when his wife
got sick he really took care of her man
it was something to see
because that's no joke dealing with
someone who has Alzheimer's for all
intents and purposes because they get
taken away from you piece by piece and
that is not pretty and then it's also
hard right not only is it catastrophic
but it's hard Jesus he just stepped into
that like perfectly and it was way less
awful than it could have been Wayne it
was just a tragedy
it wasn't hell and then I was there when
she died
and my wife's family are actually pretty
good at dealing with death as it turns
out my wife's sister is appellative care
nurse and you have to be pretty tough
cookie to be a palliative care nurse but
you can do it which is pretty
interesting because that means that you
can go make relationships with people at
the last stages of their life that are
genuine relationships and people just
died on you non-stop and yet you know
she's a competent alive alert fun person
it's like two thumbs up for her man
that's someone you can rely on in a
tragedy and her other sister is a
pharmacist and my wife has volunteered
in palliative care wards and is also
very good at taking care of people who
are genuinely not in good health and so
we were there when my mother-in-law died
and of course you could imagine here's a
here's a deathbed situation for you your
mother-in-law is dying and everyone's at
each other's throats it's like you think
that's uncommon then your eyes aren't
open because it's plenty bloody common
and then it's not just a tragedy as hell
and like maybe you can stand the tragedy
but you can't stand the hell and in this
situation that is what happens
but he pulled together and what happened
was well she died but what was so
interesting was the family actually came
together more tightly as a consequence
and so although there was something
taken away on the one hand there was
something gained on the other that
wasn't trivial and I'm not not trying to
be all optimistic and you know isn't the
universe a wonderful place about all
this like someone died in an ugly way
and it was harsh but God it was a hell
of a lot better than it could have been
and maybe it was good enough that's the
thing you know is that this is something
that I constantly wonder is that if
people did what they could to speak the
truth and pay attention then maybe the
tragedy that's part of life
wouldn't have to deteriorate into the
unbearable hell that doesn't have to be
part of life and maybe we could actually
tolerate the tragedy or maybe we could
even rise above it or maybe we could
even mitigate it you don't because we
can we do that sort of thing all the
time and so it's always an open question
and iliad had put it very well are the
floods the consequence of the fact that
things fall apart or are the floods of
consequence of the fact that people make
mistakes that they know they shouldn't
make and make anyways they sin right and
that's to miss the mark right because
that's an archery turn to sin and that
means maybe they don't even specify the
damn target which is really you're not
going to hit it unless you specified or
having specified it they just say Oh to
hell with it it's not that important
it's like you got to be careful when you
say something like to hell with it it's
not that important because one of the
things that might happen to you if you
say to hell with it it's not that
important is that you might actually end
up in hell for a pretty prolonged period
of time or maybe for the remainder of
your miserable existence because it's
certainly the case that people do exist
there and I've seen them exist there and
once you're there it's no trick it's no
simple matter to get the hell out and so
it might matter that the things that
matter get addressed it might matter
that you do what you can to walk with
like I said we'll talk more about next
time and it might be that that is how
you build an ark and are protected from
the flood even if the damn thing comes
and the thing is it will and this is a
funny thing too that I've noticed about
our education system and the way we
teach students and their trigger
warnings and all of that absolute
rubbish I think in most of my lectures
I'd have to have a trigger warning every
15 seconds so I like how my students
when they're young it's like look don't
fool yourself you know you're going to
develop a serious illness at least one
maybe two or three and one of them is
likely to be chronic and if it isn't you
it's going to be someone you love it's
going to be your husband it's going to
be your parent it's going to be your
kids that's coming and so is a lot of
death and Sand pain and so like just
exactly what sort of person are you
going to be when that shows up and
that's the right question it isn't how
are you going to be happy in your life
it's like good luck with that
it's a stupid ambition anyways as far as
I'm concerned because it's too shallow
you know happiness you're lucky that
comes it comes and goes like the Sun
coming out from behind the cloud if
you're happy man more power to you enjoy
it enjoy it it's a it's a gift from the
cosmos to be happy but a pursuit no no
the pursuit is when the dam flood comes
you want to be the person who built Ark
and that's what the story of Noah is
about and the thing is the flood is
always coming that's another thing
that's worth commenting on with regards
to this story is you know there's an
apocalyptic element to the
judeo-christian tradition there's an
idea that the end of the world is always
at hand and that you should prepare to
be judged and the thing about that is
it's true and the reason it's true is
because the end of your world is at hand
and it will certainly come and when it
comes you will be judged because it will
be up to you to figure out what to do
with the fact that your world just
collapsed and that'll be a moral problem
of ultimate severity because it will
push you right to your limits and you'll
find out exactly where your unaddressed
weaknesses lie because that's what
happens in a crisis and so the reason
that that's an archetypal reality and it
lurks underneath the entire
judeo-christian structure the apocalypse
the impending apocalypse is because we
always live in apocalyptic times and
your world is always in small ways and
large ways coming to an end and so what
do you do you prepare for it you prepare
for your world to come to an end and
then maybe when the end comes you get
another world that'd be a good deal so
we're ready for this next week
my question was regarding the online
university you plan to create and yet
the plans you up for that mine we've
spoke briefly last week and I want to
ask you how can a student such as myself
get involved with this process yeah well
an online University that's a group
perhaps a grandiose ambition right but
one of the things that so here's my
here's my rationale you know lots of
things have dramatically transformed in
the last 20 years and whole swathes of
enterprises being wiped out that's
happening in a more and more rapid rate
as our technology progresses right now
newspapers are in the process of dying I
actually think they're in the process of
committing suicide but they're in the
process of dying and that's going to
happen very rapidly I think The Globe
and Mail lost 10% of its readership in
the last three months something like
that and so what happens is that new
technologies come along to supplant the
old technologies and I've watched a
number of businesses fail some large
businesses I knew some people who worked
at Digital Equipment Corporation when it
was failing and I've had some inside
track into failing businesses and I see
when they start to fail they tend to the
failure process tends to cap and then
accelerate can have an unbelievably good
thing and this is what it looks to me
this is how it looks to me in
relationship to the universities
especially in the US although not only
especially in the humanities although
not only so number one so I recorded
three years of my personality lecture
say so let's have three years of
lectures on Freud now what I should do
with those I think is added them into
one really good lecture on Freud and
then stop giving that lecture because
why would I give that lecture again
because I've already given it and it
said it events in good shape and if it's
a really good lecture then why does
someone else have to give the lecture or
why does 300 other people have to give a
lecture on Freud you know what I mean
what's going to happen is there's going
to be some really good
extras on subjects and that's all that
people are going to need or want because
the internet tends to move things
towards winner-take-all very very
rapidly and so it seems to me that we're
already at a point technologically where
we could identify a hundred things that
people really need to know and do a
sequence of lectures on those things
that we're outstanding and then they
could be updated and added to but the
den it's like it's a done game and it's
free so I know it started thinking about
this last year when I noticed that my
psychology lectures had a million views
and that was last April and I thought
that's amazing a million views it's like
what the hell that's I don't know what
to make of that that's that's the best
that's the kind of bestselling book that
you never write because no one ever
writes a best-selling book so a million
views that's something to pay attention
to now it's way more than that but
there's videos and podcasts and that
means that people can listen when you're
doing other things too and so that's
really cool and maybe people can listen
better than they can read that's a real
possibility because we've only been
really silent Lee for about almost of
like most of humanity for less than a
hundred years and virtually no one could
read silently 500 years ago it's a
really new skill and so maybe we're
better at listening and so all of a
sudden is the possibility of
disseminating high-quality educational
material highly produced highly vetted
to millions of people for nothing well
how are you going to compete with that
then then it's worse because the
humanities which have become completely
degenerated almost completely degenerate
in my estimation have abandoned their
valuable intellectual property which is
the collective wisdom at least for the
west of Western civilization's just
sitting there someone might as well
steal it back and then there's the
Student Loan debacle in the United
States that's pronounced properly
debacle debate debacle okay obviously
I've read that word more than said it
and so you know and so you know I write
me today and he asked if you should go
to a private college for twenty-two
thousand dollars a year to Purdue it
pretty
is to pursue an undergraduate in in
psychology so that he could get into
clinical graduate school or go to
another University of State University
for far less I told them to go to the
State University because it's the wise
economic decision but you know it
doesn't seem to me that it's reasonable
at all to load people up when they're 22
with $100,000 of student debt that they
cannot declare bankruptcy for it's
indentured servitude and the and to load
up people when they're 22 or 23 with
dead of that magnitude it's like how the
hell are they going to be entrepreneurs
who are going to take a risk with a
hundred thousand dollar debt load and
who's going to marry you
so really Jesus you know because another
story I heard recently was well I just
got married to my partner she brought
into the marriage one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars of student debt it's
like oh my god it's like it's crippling
man like once you're once you're making
a substantial amount of money if you're
fortunate maybe you're in your 40s you
could handle a dead load like that but
in your 20s it's just crippling so you
know the tuition fees of Ratt ratcheted
up like mad in the last 30 years the
unity colleges and universities have
become unbelievably administrative
leeteuk heavy they're regulated to death
by the by the legislative system so
there's ethics committees which are so
counterproductive that it's just
unbelievable there's this entire whole
whole new monstrous hyper accommodation
movement that it's big borders on I
don't eat well I'll make a video about
that soon enough it's absolutely
pathological and there's this whole
postmodern neo-marxist idiocy that's
going on in the universities and so like
how many mistakes does an Institute Plus
students aren't being taught how to
speak they're not being taught how to
debate they're not being taught how to
write and they don't read difficult
things they read French intellectual
postmodernists right and they probably
don't read those either they read
secondarily derived pit they skim
secondarily derived papers about French
intellectual post Marxist post modernist
from the 1970s and the standards have
been lowered because there's too many
people pursuing higher education and so
I think okay there's eight dimensions of
success
and on every single dimension there's
failure the system's done the end so the
vision would be why not provide
everybody in the world with high quality
education in the humanities for like
150th the cost you can charge for
accreditation that's a whole separate
issue right accreditation but that what
the resources like why not make them
available to everyone so that's the plan
I mean I don't know if I can do it or
not but it's partly what I'm doing with
this biblical lecture series it's sort
of putting my toe in the water but I
have a plan and I have some good
programmers who are willing to help and
there's lots of people out there that
would help God and be flooded with
offers of help I'd love to take people
up on the offers but it's not that easy
to get someone to help you do something
you know it so that'd be the plan it's
like so what would the plan be give
people a high quality education in the
classic humanities teach them how to
speak and write accredit them for one
tenth the current cost and do it with
millions of people instead of tens of
thousands some I'm asking what plans
Jeff for the accreditation side where
people can show something for what's the
time these don't watch well one of the
things that I would do for example is
imagine that you are in a course and so
you have taken exam let's say it's a
multiple-choice exam just for the sake
of argument because they're simpler the
writing issue is a separate problem well
so one of the things that you would do
if you enrolled in the course is
generate multiple-choice questions that
would be one of your assignments here's
a lecture generate 10 multiple-choice
questions now you go to thousand people
generating 10 multiple-choice questions
well then you can do there are
statistical procedures that help you
figure out what valid multiple choice
questions are could have people vote on
them for that matter if you put them on
a website assignment number two here's a
hundred multiple choice questions pick
the ten that you think are most
representative of the knowledge that
you've acquired get a hundred people to
do that so you get crowdsource the test
construction and then you can keep
making the test better and better as
well because you could build that I'd
like to build the system so that it was
self improving with a minimum of
administrative interference and so
then what would happen is that as you
got accredited so you start writing
exams and maybe write more and more of
them then you'd start to by voting power
with regards to the content of the
courses and maybe even the right to
produce courses to put them up online so
it's something like that but our
strategy would be to build we want to
build a system that's basically
autonomous and self-improving right from
the beginning so minimum of
administrative overhead extremely low
cost widespread availability
crowd-sourced in its structure and an
autonomously self-improving I think we
can do that I don't know if I can do it
but I think we have the technology to do
that and then you think well so here's
the plan you know because you're are I'm
always thinking of the point point B
what what's a good thing to do with life
well the good good thing to do with your
life is the most difficult god damn you
thing you can think of that would do the
most possible good that'll get you up in
the morning and so because you think why
should I get up in the morning it's like
well you know I've got 50 million people
to educate hey that'll do it really you
know that's that battle that will
overcome a lot of eggs
that's sort of thinking so well so it
seems to me that it seems to me that
it's inevitable now whether or not I can
do it that's a whole different story but
I can certainly start it and I'm going
to start it my partner my business
partner the guy who helped me develop
the self authoring program which
thousands of people are using that now
and we've helped thousands of thousands
of students now stay in the university
so that's really cool well maybe not
given the state of the university I'm
contributing to the problem but you know
but they're but they're sticking out
their plans that's the point they're
actually making plans and sticking them
out so so I think that we can and we
know how to start small with because the
way to build a big system is to build a
small system that works and then scale
it and so that's I've been talking with
my partner his name is Daniel Higgins
another partner Bob Peel he used to be
my graduate supervisor at McGill and
we've been working on this sort of thing
for about 25 years and our goal
being right from the beginning to build
low-cost high-quality psycho-educational
interventions and bring them to as wide
a market as possible so and then my and
Daniel in particular has devoted most of
his life to doing that it's been about
20 years now so so well that's a sketch
of it all outline more of it on the web
at some point but that's kind of what's
what we've been deciding what we've been
planning to do yep look when you were on
the Rubin report not too long ago in
that discussion you mentioned how use of
psilocybin straightens people out and
can produce these transcendent
experiences which is jarring for a
person who may have personally wanted
lesion that on the rubin which were
happy with for someone who became a
christian as a result of their only time
doing magic mushrooms was during piece
of information I was just wondering if
you could expand on what you find
intriguing about religious experience
and what we can know about the
transcendent from them if anything
that's a tough one man um
the relationship between entheogen
accuse let's say which is sometimes what
those chemicals are described and
religious experience is unspecified but
it looks like it's profound there was a
man named Gordon was saw who wrote a
book I remember correctly called soma he
was investigating the potential use of
Hema NIDA muscaria mushrooms among the
people who wrote the Hindu holy
scriptures thousands of years ago and he
felt that he identified the chemical
that they were using the sacred drink
the use of ayahuasca and psilocybin
mushrooms and so forth is
well-documented particularly in North
America and the evidence the empirical
evidence that under certain conditions
those chemicals can produce religious
experiences is absolutely overwhelming
that has been good research done
recently at Johns Hopkins looking at
psilocybin the first research that's
been done on hallucinogens really in 30
years because people were so terrified
of them in the 60s and for good reason
indicated that the people that they
dosed with psilocybin about 75 percent
of them had a mystical experience which
they regarded as one of the five three
to five most important experiences of
their life and a year later were
characterized by a permanent personality
transformation which was an increase in
trade openness of one standard deviation
which is a lot by the way it moves you
from 50th percentile to 85th percentile
for example it's a huge move and that
looked permanent now whether or not
that's a good thing that's a whole
different issue but they're very very
powerful and they also did some recent
research showing that psilocybin
mushrooms were an unbelievably effective
smoking cessation intervention so if I
remember correctly and I may have this
wrong because it's been awhile since I
read it an 80% success rate in stopping
people from using tobacco with one
psilocybin experience and so well so
those things are very all of that's very
interesting to me and I don't exactly
know what
make of it I don't know what to make of
it at all not even a little bit but but
the evidence for the relationship
between met mystical experiences and
hallucinogen use of certain types is
incontrovertible and I don't and I don't
think anybody else knows what to derive
from that I mean one conclusion is
something like religious experiences are
a common concomitant of going
temporarily insane
and that it's not a bad hypothesis
because you see for example in the
prodrome of illnesses like schizophrenia
and sometimes manic depressive disorder
- on a mannequin you do see the
emergence often of religious type
delusions it's not that common but it's
not uncommon so it's definitely the case
that if your brain function has been
detrimental E affected one of the
consequences can be experiences that are
subjectively experienced as
indistinguishable from the religious you
also see the same thing in cases of
epilepsy especially in the prodromus so
if you have an epileptic condition
sometimes you know that you're going to
have a seizure you can feel it mounting
and often or at least occasionally those
experiences are associated with an
elevation of religious sensation
deepening meaning that increases in its
depth and complexity until it's
overwhelming and that's what
subjectively brings on the seizure now
god only knows how to disentangle
causality in this circumstance like that
Dostoevsky had seizures like that by the
way so so that the the pessimistic
viewpoint is religious phenomenology is
a consequence of brain disorder the
positive side more positive side is no
religious experience is a category of
experience that's within the realm of
human possibility and there are
different modes of eliciting it and we
know that there are many modes of
eliciting it's
stinkin elicited dancing under some
circumstances music and elicited music
elicits it regularly I mean basically as
far as I'm concerned rock concerts are
indistinguishable from religious rituals
their rituals not like they don't come
with dogmatic overlay let's say but the
ritualistic structure is there and maybe
it's there just listening to music what
that means for the investigation of
hallucinogens I have no idea and I would
also certainly use the caution that Carl
Jung developed when he was talking about
hallucinogens and he did that I think
only a very brief number of times and I
think in relationship to Aldous Huxley's
original work on mescaline experiences
he said beware of wisdom that you didn't
earn and that's very very smart so I
would say there's something to be
learned about there's something there's
a lot to be learned about hallucinogens
there may be something to be learned
from them but having said that if you
play with fire you end up burnt
generally speaking so all due caution is
in effect so one more I know you're now
the Flex Lee fan so I thought I'd ask
you this question after reading his book
doors of perception in which he gives an
account of his experience taking the
psychedelic drug mescaline he stated
that in the final stages of egolessness
there is an obscene knowledge that all
isn't all that all was actually each he
then went out to say that this is as
near I take it as a finite mind can ever
get to perceiving everything that is
happening in the universe I was
wondering if maybe you could explain
what that means because I've been trying
to understand it for a monster
there's the neuroscientist a while back
his name I don't remember who had a
stroke and she being a neuroscientist
was analyzing the neurological
consequences of the stroke as it
occurred if I remember correctly the
stroke either temporarily or more
permanently took out the function of
large portions of her left hemisphere
and she had exactly that experience it
was an experience of ego dissolution
something like that that the the felt
sense of identity shifting from that
sort of narrow boundaries maybe that you
would define by the boundary of your
physical being into something that was
much broader and much like it gets it
gets it gets hard to describe this
without you know degenerating into hippy
poetry from 1967 very very rapidly but
it's something like a sense a sense of
of the underlying unity of consciousness
that might be one way of thinking about
we don't know much about consciousness
in fact I don't think we know anything
about consciousness and obviously
consciousness is something that we all
share but it's also something that we
seem to also experience individually but
maybe our individual consciousnesses are
something like the manifestations of
something that's a more unified
consciousness underneath I mean that's
hardly an original idea but it does seem
to be the case that under some
circumstances there are neurological
transformations that make that link more
apparent assuming that the link exists
now you could say well no they're just
producing a delusion but the funny thing
about you know funny thing about
delusions is that you've got to think
well how do you know something's a
delusion and the answer that has to be
like something like well hardly anyone
else thinks that that would be criterion
number one but criterion number two
would be if you act on the delusion does
your ship sink because if your sip sinks
then it was a delusion it's some
like that but if you act on your
delusion and things get better well then
maybe it wasn't a delusion and there's
no evidence from the psilocybin studies
that have been conducted at Johns
Hopkins that there was detrimental
effects for the participants and the
participants certainly don't think the
day effects are detrimental so and I've
been hesitant to talk about any of this
for obvious reasons haha I'll tell you
something really funny I think it's
funny anyways I had Timothy Leary's old
job at Harvard so you know and so Leary
is a good object lesson and being very
careful about this sort of thing because
it certainly it isn't obvious that his
net effect was good and I say that with
some caution because Leary was a very
smart person and he was very creative
but he got tangled up in that
hallucinogenic madhouse you know that
that characterized the say the period
from 1965 to about 1970 and it didn't
seem to me that that was altogether a
good thing thing is we have these
chemicals now in our culture and people
are experimenting with them like mad and
making them illegal doesn't seem to be
working in large part because there I
think there were seven known seven to
twenty known psychoactive substances
that were illegal in the year 2000
there's something like 400 now because
labs all over the world keep tweaking
the molecules right because molecule a
is illegal so chemists just shifted a
little bit and they have a new
hallucinogen and which might be fine and
might not be because now and then you
can produce a chemical that's
unbelievably dangerous fentanyl sort of
like that there was a drug a while back
that I could name I can't remember the
name it was an acronym it was a fun drug
if you took it once it gave you
permanent irreversible total Parkinson's
disease so people would take it and they
were frozen and that was it so MPTP I
think it was called so because it
destroyed the same area of the brain
that that Parkinson's destroys accepted
in it right away so you know designer
drugs right
a little caution is in order how we
might approach the issue of hallucinogen
use in a mature manner well that's a
topic for an entirely other discussion
I'm not even necessarily sure that it
can be approached that way although I
would say at minimum determining what it
is that you're up to if you're going to
experiment would be a good thing like
what is it exactly that you're serving
they're not party drugs and not for fun
right whatever they are that's not what
they're for and so maybe they could be
used by people who are carefully
orienting themselves towards the good
although I wouldn't say that that should
be read as a recommendation thank you
yep the theory next week thank you